oh my God this is so nice this is The
Pick of Destiny this is so cool thank
you so much my God what a nice gift
thank you so
much you know um what what what is that
pick made of it's like solid Stone right
it's like it's Jade I think they oh the
Jade right that's sick I wonder if you
can shred with a
stone the piad bro we'll have to see
some videos of that yeah I'm excited
thank you very much it very cool very
nice GI awesome very nice thank you and
thank you so much to uh emerald and the
crew for coming in I really appreciate
you guys uh and so up and Ela you can go
ahead and join us now uh that we're
moving on from the the Jade cutting
which was so exciting and so much fun
but alas there's so much still to do uh
welcome everybody it is
the next show of the
week uh thank you to Gamers sub Shopify
and hexclad who we
love we love them man we love our
sponsors and you know who else I love
Ela oh thank you I know love a braak St
to take but it is how you doing all
right this is from the new drop yes it
is El is in her goth I know
her goth stage you want to show anything
else um I don't have much to show it's
just a baby I love yourself oh you've
got fat Jorts on those are definitely
have Js on but they're like R JS yeah
the whole outfit looks so good thank you
dude you just got straight up raver
jorks raver jorks my dude it's a Vibe
survive um briefly want to say that the
the teddy FR drop is out
came out yesterday it's a fan favorite
everybody is loving it they're losing
their minds people are having trouble
deciding what is which item do I want
that's my it is I'll just scroll over it
this is all available right now on Teddy
fresh.com if there's anything you want
to say Ela go ahead the W you just
scrolled by is really fun it's a thermal
fabric like this is it like this yeah I
love the WAFF like the waffle so cozy
fabric it's my favorite Fab
um this jacket is just gorgeous in
person it's cordor and it's got a wash
and then the lining is like jacket
colorful plaid I don't know if anybody I
have it right here oh show the int
lining it's beautiful damn son what the
what are
those damn I need that I got to say the
stuff is
really coming through we had a little
bit of a theme of like the world ending
so some of the graphics are like the one
you scrolled by just now this one quit
disrespecting my
mother your mama is so
fat she got a whole ass ocean in sorry
on her butt crack I don't
know I'm sorry
I'm and then that's the same jacket in
Orange lots of corduroy eh these pants
are also very comfy it's like
a jogger in a way because it has elastic
waste um elastic at the bottom and it's
a tie-dye it's quarter ey more waffles
on the beanie Yep this shirt's sick I
got to get some of get me some of them
do do I get grab a couple of these Lena
yep we have some in the back for you
thank you beautiful dress this dress is
great I love that one I have to put it
on oh I almost wore it today I couldn't
decide what to wear it's so
beautiful yeah the puffers are crazy the
jackets are crazy the s are crazy I love
this
hat which one oh there you go oh yeah
got so the square what do you call that
rectangle beanie looks like a whale tail
it's
rectangular it's the Sean
Stevens uh the Bears Bonet the Bears
it's all happening here at Teddy
fresh.com I love the bear
sprunchie
the sweater the shirt it's all happening
guys go there now Teddy fresh.com thank
you thank you peace and this dress is a
recut of the we had it previously in
this like pink iridescent color so now
it's in silver this one is we were
thinking like for the holidays that are
going to be coming up soon you can wear
it as a jacket or as a dress there it is
versatility versatility you can't find
anywhere else frankly is the lighting
normal I feel like I look dark but I
don't know if it's just the preview
monor right I don't know sometimes if
it's just the TV that we have here or I
don't know if my eyes dude my eyes are
have they gotten better Ela would you
say no really okay it's still all around
your eye I I thought maybe it was you
know I thought maybe it was getting a
little better maybe a little but it's
been a [__] like over a week now I
don't know how long it takes for this
[__] to go away I need a new doctor
that's what I keep telling Ethan I think
he needs to see somebody else because
doesn't make sense you said
she TR I need you know what I need is
acupuncture right in my [__]
rash Lena you said she was going to send
a new medicine mhm it's here we got it
for you oh we got it it's an antibiotic
you want to bring it I'll put it on
antibiotic an oral one it's oral yeah
what does that wait what she I'm just an
oral
antibiotic can you bring it here they're
normally they're more commonly oral I
believe that doesn't even make sense
does it just say you have an infection
balls in my mouth I hate taking
antibiotics bro the last time I did that
was pesto I don't take it until you see
another doctor I don't I'm not ready for
another pesto situation and neither are
you guys right we are not ready either
for that let me
see you're not there you're not there
you're not
there in a nightmare it's a nightmare
it's a nightmare I
can't you know um we've been getting
some great submissions now's a good time
to remind everybody that next
Wednesday uh Our Song remix holy [__]
they gave me
pills twice a day what the
hell hit that [__] I don't understand
should we you know what they think that
you have though to give you antibiotics
I don't think they know they're just
like here try this she said something
about helping with
inflammation really yeah I can text her
now I'm going to need a chat you know
what listen I'm not I'm no doctor I'm
going to ask chat chat I think chat
would know let's ask chat should I take
the antibiotics or no against my
doctor's orders who's is right who's by
the way I'm getting less and
less uh faith in oh by the way you
didn't show but we finally did a scarf
hit that [__] oh yeah I saw in the
beginning was the checked one
yeah why am I taking I just I I'm really
I don't want to take antibiotics you
know I feel like I've got a good uh yeah
my genan or uh my flora I've got a good
Flora situation MH the bacterias are
vibing now is not the time grab one of
those healing crystals oh yeah yeah rub
it on your face I got shungite they gave
me sh put that sh on your face breaking
news people are overwhelmingly voting to
listen to the
doctor weird also I'm going to text you
get more information for you do you have
any specific question I just I prefer
not to take an antibiotic I think that's
a bad poll though it's a bad poll I
think you guys are wrong wait is the
poll bad yeah cuz because it's yes or
don't listen to your doctor you're
stupid I wouldn't put it hold on I do
think it's fair because it is dumb for
us lay it to not listen to their dog
right do find the characterization but I
know but the question is more does it
make sense that they gave him
antibiotics right now right
that someone said bofit I was just
thinking
that let's get straight to the pesto
when you put up your butt specifically
when drugs up your butt actually so boof
it yeah boof it poop It Go twist it
crush it up and snort it yeah get the
first to
flatulence um so I guess it just ask her
it how necessary is
it it's so oh can you hear me
Lena oh okay she's she she's she's
busy I hope you can hear me back there
um yeah so call to action deadline is
Wednesday next week for the dream
nightmare remix competition it is oh
happening
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
oh so triumphant so
beautiful I am
I'm
Zion Oh very exciting very
exciting
um so we have a lot of really fun stuff
planned today first of all following
Emerald's appearance here she gave us a
lead so she says she's a gemman gems
woman can I say gemman is that cuz like
a gems person cuz now they say actor
where it used to be actress when I was a
kid but now they're using actor as
act anymore right but that doesn't have
man in it so when it comes to the
G Smith Women's in women in gem women in
gem nice thank you I didn't hear you AB
not I said uh wom in gem a playoff of
women in stem women in stem oh wow I
didn't it was a good joke I I did hear
you I just didn't understand the word
just pretend when you see my mouth move
women gem
uh
okay anyway what do so she she's a rock
expert like there's one passion she
shared with us that she says is even
more powerful that she's more passionate
about and it's chocolate she informed us
chocolate that there's an a chocolate
place here in town called and Sons a
name that confused me at the time
frankly does a little bit and Sons
cuz it sends like hands usually it's
like a name and Sons right like oia and
Sons yeah and sons who okay okay and
what you know but here's the really
exciting
part so Sam went and bought chocolates
there
chocolet but the guy one of the sons
reached out to us W in the wake of that
uh segment not the son he says he called
himself son number two oh yeah I don't
know how many there
are I was hoping for number one but yeah
I think there's
two you think they are like little oal
loas they wear like overalls with a big
number on it and he has like a big two
yeah number one number
two that's what I'm expecting I hope but
he's coming actually and he's bringing a
massive uh where's my Shala sample tray
a ton of them for us and I'm so excited
so excited I've never been this excited
but she said and this
this this lady Emerald is a person of
class and taste yeah I if she says it's
the best chocolate in the world mhm that
I'm [__] listening you know what we
have to do I was listening I literally
took note of the name immediately I
wrote it down on my phone yeah good we
got to send her one of the boxes cuz he
said he's bringing like a bunch of big
ass sample boxes that would be cool
defend she would love that no one would
love it more than her and we love
Emerald don't we F and the whole crew
they were
fantastic fun wholesome segment did you
see her sweater was so cute so cute oh
yeah she wore for you she said the teddy
bear one so cute
yeah uh so uh there's that there's so
much more one thing at the top I think
maybe I'll just do it is the title of
the episode breaking new evidence in the
Mr Beast Scandal who this is not
clickbait I new evidence we are having
someone of a
breaking uh we are breaking a story kind
of right well yeah I I think so
absolutely I think so and I'm I'm going
to be re totally real about this whole
thing okay really but basically to bring
you guys up to dat Rosanna poncino who
called into the show on was it this week
was it was it last Friday no it was a
week ago last Friday last Friday yeah um
it's been been a long week it has been
why is that that's it has been I don't
know maybe it's because there's a war I
don't know war war war war never changes
it feels like a month ago when she was
here with no show on Thursday somehow my
week feels
longer also that Halloween thing cuz I F
the
Halloween it's
Friday went back to work next day so so
true anyway she came on the show she had
a pretty compelling story about um
basically how Mr Beast eded her out of
the top three uhhuh uh and how quacky
according to her won the competition she
should have got second
place but Logan or no M Jimmy and his
team Mr Beast they edited it so that
Logan
Paul uh Zach
King and who was the third
I don't remember I don't remember but
the weird thing was like Logan didn't
even that
[__] that was lay Logan didn't even
place he got like fifth yeah like there
was no yeah but they like made it seem
like he was but lay fell asleep and was
eliminated Shenanigans like he performed
better yeah lots of shenanigans you so
um so anyway
after this was on the 29th when was that
well that must have been the beginning
of this week right 29 no that was Friday
so she oh was the same day mhm 2 12:
a.m. I guess it was later that evening
or yeah so she she issued an
apology she said I would like to
apologize to Mr Beast I should have
expressed my feelings privately and
handled things directly I will be moving
all of the posts where I talk about
creator games and Jimmy I will be honest
in that the thousands of death threats
I've received received today are a
contributing factor but I also sin do
also sincerely hear the feedback from so
many of
you dude she here she's too green she
she's Green in the world of uh yeah
internet drama she you know what I mean
like you could tell she just was she
wasn't ready yeah right uh but
but but uh you
know she's been on the internet long
enough so here's just you know welcome
to the club
true it's a it's a trial by fire but
then interestingly she redacted the
apology she redacted the
redaction she changed her mind no that's
a new one she came back this is actually
a new one in terms of YouTube apologies
yeah I I've never seen a redaction of a
redaction let's go she said I redact my
apology to Mr Beast of not setting
things
privately based on recent new
information and developments behind the
scenes I have learned that certain
issues will never be quote handled
privately they'll only be dismissed or
covered up privately moving forward I do
promise not to drop an ill-timed music
video that also happened we didn't yeah
she I a th% believe her that it was it's
that this accusation that she's trying
to promote her music video is silly and
dumb as hell I don't think anyone
actually believes that uh Rosana if
you're watching but that's obviously
dumb but she dropped a music video and
so everyone was like oh she's trying to
promote music video Whatever not just
any music video what was
it it was the
band it was the band yeah the band what
song was it the bad luck band oh yeah
with the band cence Klein water oh
that Excuse excuse my reference
gotcha Klein water B I really don't want
to eat already at the stop of the show
but [__] that is so good holy [__] so we
we are trying to become grown steak one
spicy dude I'm freaking out it's so fre
good spicy it's so and so we were saying
let's start ordering before the show and
settle that whole conversation not on
air this not good but this is worse
because the food came in so fast I don't
know what to do now we just started now
we're already eating so I think we have
to do it in the middle or like really
really early yeah what if we like really
really early we before
through the show well you you guys could
have ordered it whenever you wanted you
guys ordered it like an hour ago we
should order it when you guys arrive I
think I that's that would probably work
yeah so I'm going to set this aside I'm
not going to do that to you guys
um she said yeah moving forward I do
promise not to drop an ill Time music
video completely poor timing my bad and
will word things more clearly in the
future never my intention to downplay
anyone's
experience wait when did she you do
that never my intention to downplay
anyone's
experiences oh I don't know uh I don't
know I guess people were saying she was
using language that was like yeah maybe
because it was on it it was on Twitter
and like people are speaking in like
when when you use cryptic language like
that I think some people assume you're
speaking about the conflict that's going
on world right now maybe I think people
are saying she us the language of
someone who's like making a essay
allegation or something like me too but
she did she did say that she's not ready
to speak about an experience that she
had that was along those lines and that
this was her standing her ground in
being a part of other people's projects
well if it's not about that I don't know
what she's talking
about I think that is probably what it's
about though um God damn it I got to
take this away it was a beautiful music
video I watched it mhm you want to put
it in the fridge what do you want to do
no cuz if you fridge it it'll get soggy
it'll just ruin it I'm going to have to
just leave it here and hopefully when
someone else is talking I can take a
bite I can put on the subway sound
effects it's too early for the sub too
early we're doing our main segment we're
losing them it is what it is
brother must be nice to be you guys just
sitting there eating your [__]
sandwiches happy as can be I'm going to
set mine aside in solidarity with you
about this is amazing I just down mine
so I'm ready to go dude you guys know
we're doing a podcast here like the
audio is kind of a big deal we can't
just sit here with loud ass rappers
[__] eating sandwiches smack lipsa
with your mouth open what kind of show
is this dude the best show on Earth
we're just eating like a whole ass room
while talking it's insane I enjoy
mukbangs I hate them it's a it's a whole
genre it's
beautiful we have mute switches so yeah
it does change we're okay what are you
eating AB huh what are you eating uh
[Music]
Capri
wow my
god wow Zach what the hell was that that
was quick Zach's on he's it's that
guitar pick the [__] Stone dude this
thing's [__] awesome bro yeah so
anyway I'm just learning to find my own
voice and be safe space for others okay
so she redacted her apology but then you
think it's done yeah it's not done she
erased it her redaction of her redaction
okay so I have a qu I have a very
important question she erased this tweet
that I just read right no yep when you
when you redact a redaction what are are
you have you reset to neutral at that
point or are you back to the AP is the
is the apology back on is what I'm
wondering because she retracted the
apology but now that retraction is gone
so we default back to the apology now
everything's gone so now it's just she
has no opinion about it he doesn't exist
okay this is a paradox my friend she
deleted everything everything's gone she
did it the first time and then she says
no I take it back and then she erased
that one but she never said I redact my
redaction of my redaction right that's
erased it that's why I feel like we're
in limbo right now
yeah rewind time I want more yeah we're
waiting for clarification dude I think
it would be so funny if she just kept
going man I think so I think it would be
really really is she an apology for that
react like if she if she was in on it
she was just like sorry I think that'd
be a beautiful Twitter moment not but
the good news is guys the best and
brightest the UN peacekeepers are on the
scene
keemstar says Mr Beast and Rosanna Pino
have made peace yes I facilitated a call
with both of them and they both
apologized after getting better
understanding of each person's
perspective get this man to Gaza yeah
please it was a very productive call
hide and goh seat gate has officially
ended or has it keemstar shut up is he
just there's is there what did they
really do that [__] no you think he's
making that up a joke why would no I
don't know I thought he was serious I
think he's got to be exaggerating his
involvement why the [__] would he why
would Mr Beast get on the phone with he
the Elder Statesman of YouTube maybe he
talked to her and said you should give
him a call and that was it you should
talk to him about it I think I think
there's probably some truth but also a
great exaggeration yeah exactly yeah but
uh you know what man this makes no sense
who talked to who keemstar talked and he
figured it out we love him for that
don't we folks so no I'm waiting for for
the I would like to un ruct my call with
them Keem put a statement I just got a
message from Rosanna I was issued told
instructed to say that the understanding
was
redacted so frustated was this after her
latest tweet was erased this is the most
I think this is the L this is the latest
update this is breaking so there's news
oh boy there's peace in the Middle East
yep okay well then here's it gets kind
of interesting so peace in the middle
Beast
this that's in the middle be Twitter
drafts not put it out Absol yeah that
was a good call that that absolutely not
yeah it not a banger take it from a b
however it Rhymes so it did po a good
one it's a good one in Minecraft yeah
what what you
doing so here's where we have new
information since we had the interview
with
Rosanna we've been getting emails from
Anonymous
tipsters that have pointed out I know
cheers myud they pointed out some
weirdness SL inconsistencies with Mr
Beast video and you know with these
kinds of things I think they're so I
never buy this [__] but what's
interesting is that a lot of what this
guy told us we were able to cross
reference with public information to
confirm at least that there might be
Something Fishy going on here and so I'm
going to present this information you
guys as partially as I can I'm not
trying to accuse him of anything and I
don't think there is proof but what
we're seeing is
basically that Jimmy is presenting like
random subscribers are being picked to
be in his videos and what the people
that are actually in his videos are
employees oo and so look is it the
biggest crime in the world no well is it
a little is it misleading I think so is
it could be a crime I don't know there's
a lot of money involved yeah could
actually I mean so here's the thing the
anonymous tipster said and this is fully
uncorroborated this is just a straight
up
allegation hearsay that he does this as
part of their compensation package that
they'll be included in a competition in
one of his videos that is just pure hear
say but it is interesting because
basically from what we've been able to
tell we found three different
situations one of them by pure happen
happen chance when when Dan was working
to uh yeah one I just kind of stumbled
into um I should say one of them I don't
think is very slam dunk by any means um
it's just it's a little bit more
ambiguous uh the other two they are
presented as random people
[Music]
and evidence seems to indicate they are
not random people so I just wonder like
whenever these things are involving so
much money there's Al also like a lot of
I mean you from an accounting
perspective and legality that was part
of I wonder if this is all legit because
I don't know remember when we wanted to
do like the fish tank or something like
that and it was actually kind of
complicated super complicated that we
didn't do it yeah because there's all
kinds of legal [__] you got to deal
with but you're right because he's doing
competitions he is doing giveaways and
those are actually regulated
specifically
regulated things in the United States
however I I think my first reaction to
all this stuff was like there's no way
he's
that careless cuz it it just seems
careless you know like well here's the
thing such a slick operation they seem
to have all their [__] together right it
just kind of surprised me to see this
level of inconsistency just out there
blaring in the in the public and maybe
there's a good explanation for all of it
well you're right that there is uh a lot
of regulations around like sweep stakes
and public contests and everything but
maybe you know he is sidest stepping
that by it it doesn't really matter how
it's being presented in the video right
it's more if he actually is running a a
sweep I'm lawyer I don't know it's
totally a question for lawyers and
accountants right yeah but I'm less
concerned about the legality and more so
just
like people he has this crazy engagement
because people think he's like real life
Willie wonan they're going to get a
chance to tour the Chocolate Factory yep
no even if all this is true that's still
happening he's definitely still bringing
random Subs to compete so you you guys
you know I'm going to present the
information as as we have it so the
first one's about a dude named Sean hris
who appeared at a Mr Beast video
published in September of last year he
was introduced right at the beginning as
a random subscriber here is the
[Music]
clip um wait this is just the beginning
is that where oh yeah here so here this
comes from Mr Beast video titled surv
100 days in a circle when half a million
just for um um this this video did get
claimed Beast is claiming yeah he
claimed all of the uh so I'll just have
to dispute it okay hopefully maybe he's
got it the setting where if it's not
like well um the the relevant part of
this is just in the first few seconds of
the video we we really don't have to
watch much if you just let it play it's
like right off the bat all right well
we'll see it's we'll we'll deal with it
if if that's the case so here he goes by
the way this video has a measly 260
million
views no big deal Jes chist no big deal
in the middle of nowhere and this is a
random subscriber and if he stays boom
there you go that was him that's him so
this is the guy in question he is one
more
time I laid a giant Circle in the middle
of nowhere and this is a random giant
prolapsed anus in the middle of this
field so Random subscriber okay
yeah by the way please anyone named in
this these people these employees they
did
nothing I'm really not even trying to
put out like these guy these people did
nothing so don't [__] you know what I
mean I don't want to hear anybody
[__] with these people at
all uh they're just doing their
jobs i' to take but I'm not even fully
convinced that this is even that big of
a deal for Mr Beast I just maybe I just
have more Le like I I view what he does
as like reality TV basically and so much
of that [__] is fake it's just like it's
just kind of part of the game what I
know this is always a hot take everybody
gets mad at me but reality TV is fake as
[__] this this reminds me of that that's
the one point then that I'll never agree
with you and I take it seriously they
don't rig compe reality TV they don't
that that doesn't happen I'm offed this
is you know if he's cheating this kind
of stuff what the hell that's what
that's what people are watching for it's
part of the I know and it's and they
make it very thrilling listen we talked
about this when we were talking with
rosan it's not reality TV it's very much
part of his DNA that he's the authentic
real deal and everything that happens in
his videos is exactly as it happened
okay but like if you watch um Survivor
where they have to live in the middle of
an island for like 100 days somebody
cheated that there'd be like insanity n
they'd be illegal it's there's a whole
sportsmanship that goes into that Dan
with peace and love you got no idea what
you're talking about I feel like you got
any evidence you have any evidence you
come out here with this [__] talking on
reality TV listen I'm not saying that
the contest win they pick who's going to
win they fudge things I wouldn't go as
far as to say that they pick who's going
to win on what based off of who's
entertaining in the show if somebody is
real to me damn it
okay it's real to me Dan I I've had
enough of a hard week already with the
war going on I don't need
this you're right let me have it all
right I'm not saying it's a huge deal
either but I do think that there is
something don't tell me I'm delusional
in chat too I it matters pick winners in
a competition that'd be illegal there's
no shot they're calling me fully
delusional I need an accountant and a
lawyer right now to call in here's the
thing there's this
people have accepted as a matter of fact
that all reality TV is just 100%
manufactured I don't know I'm not saying
100% I'm not trying to make that clim
and I'm not saying and I'm saying it's
you know Mr Beast most of what he does
is real but I think he fudges stuff but
that's not what he says you don't see
people at the beginning of reality shows
being like everything that happened here
is exactly how it was happened we didn't
edit anything out of context well when
where's where's the evidence that Mr be
says that he said that on podcast a
bunch of times maybe even when we had
him on is that everything that happens
there is authentic and and he doesn't
fudge anything okay I'm sure someone can
dig that up okay I think it also depends
whether or not you categorize a Mr Beast
video as a game show or reality TV if
it's a game
show you can't cheat yeah ex Survivor I
think that they probably keep around
people who are who are entertaining but
they won't like alter the through it's
the biggest game show in the world right
now right the amount of views that he is
uh getting and the amount of money that
people are winning if you watch actual
shows on television they get like
nothing they get $50,000 let me say this
the people who are agreeing with Dan do
not watch reality TV Dan do you watch
reality TV uh be honest so I didn't I
didn't Ally Ally watches everything so I
with you call her right
now the [__] know about Scandal Dan do
you know I know all about the Scandal
she just watched all Vander no [__]
we're here talking about Vander Vander
pump rules and he's telling me how fake
it is I was like bit you even you know
nothing i' I've actually worked on some
reality you know nothing for anything I
don't know what did you see there uh
some faking [__] [__] you have nothing
I'm not saying it doesn't happen we've
talked about it on the show I I worked
on a Home Improvement reality show and
me and the other Pas did most of the
Home Improvement oh well that that
doesn't surprise me at all yeah but on
the show it's the contractors and
they're fixing up this house and really
it was meing around like C that is
different that is different that's
basically just yachty yting the boring
part like when if I ever watch one of
those shows yeah I'm not thinking the
blonde girl is doing all the work you
know T and that girl there's some PA
named Dan doing it off the screen Dan SW
it's not even really material to the
story yeah Dan we talking like Flip or
Flop uh no what was iter I shouldn't say
which one it was I mean it was years ago
probably doesn't matter but I shouldn't
say tell me later I'll tell you how fire
anyway here is um this is me right now
next question Jeff where are you right
there yeah um I just want to thank each
and every one of y'all for all you've
done to your bodies
buiness it's still real to me
Dam thank guys
you're awesome thank you so much Mr Fu
for saying what needed to be said I
don't want to see it of seriously I'm
about to cry right now spirit animal
animal love that man you got to have
some respect you see how vulnerable he
was Dan you just spit in his [__] I'm
sorry I'm sorry to that ebon's world
video you literally just folded the
bleachers and tried attempted to murder
everybody in those bleachers oh so sorry
anyway where the [__] were we get Ally
on the phone is where we
were go ahead Dan get the lawyers on the
phone ask Ally is Vander pump rules fake
okay I'll ask her right now but we're
talking about Mr Beast here not vandr oh
so now it doesn't
matter I've always said it didn't matter
it doesn't matter that's that's my
position is that it doesn't really
matter if he fudges
it to who see I don't I don't the the
the I should I I'll I'll put in the
stipulation it's different with rose
experience because there was rosan there
was a big donation of Charity money and
so like there was like a tangible thing
but when it comes think it matter hold
on hold on you don't think it matters to
his audience who think that all these
people are random subscribers and then
he's actually just picking people he
knows in real life to be on the show
yeah I guess it is that's not a great
look is it it's a little I mean it's
misleading at worst I mean at best it's
misle I guess I shouldn't say it doesn't
matter I just don't think it's uh out of
of the ordinary for this type of content
at all like I don't think Mr Beast is an
exception here I don't think Mr Beast
content has many comparisons frankly I I
there are not actually there he does it
in a specific way but I think the
closest comparison is reality TV I think
is it I would compare it to game shows
yeah game shows is a way better
comparison yeah there's tons of Japanese
game shows like this where they do
challenges and crazy [__] true true you
win something at the end reality is not
really about winning something
yeah I I mean reality is a broad
category to compare to I guess but yeah
maybe it's more like a game show Zach
can you grab that it's real to me damn
it sound bite yeah I was thinking the
same thing I'm going to need that
definitely okay can we [__] talk
about the damn accusations here I think
we're done here we're done we're done I
haven't even said anything we settled it
talk about the
allegations let's do a let's do a PLL
right now does it matter does it matter
yes or no even say what matters does it
matter does it matter question mark yes
no and to be specific when we say that
do matter we're
meaning if he's misleading about saying
that these are random people or
subscribers do you think it matters at
all that there he's actually picking
people he knows and this is the this is
the allegation this is not uh real
support supported
by exact evidence I haven't even shown
you guys the damn evidence yet just
watch
it okay thank
you I'm used to people siding with Dan
and you
know okay so we have enough people here
that says it matters D cuz I was just
about to wrap it up I was like okay
nobody
cares what am I saying terrible poll
what's the it does matter Dan this is
actually one of the best polls you've
ever done people saying the worst pole
terrible poll what the [__] is this poll
horrible po straight I've never seen a
more accurate po the worst all right all
right let's get on with
it so this is the first one Sean
Hendricks he appeared in this Mr V video
September last year and he was
introduced once again as a random
subscriber so now if we go to LinkedIn
we'll see and this is the stuff that was
sent to us by an anonymous tipster yep
cheers my dude
cheers uh and the tipster oh can I did
he love
if I'm not sharing his identity then it
doesn't matter what I
say like just there's no reason to even
say whatever you're about to say
okay so according to LinkedIn this guy
Sean Hendrick worked for Mr Bast
since
September of last year as you can see
here here he is director of development
oh that's a big that's actually a sounds
like a big role mhm
uh director of development
full-time since September so this is the
same month so it is possible MH that
they met and maybe they they clicked he
was a random subscriber brought him in
and was like Hey you work in this
industry hit it off and he ends up
hiring you want to work here that's a
possibility it is a possibility it's the
it's the same month right right so it's
interesting it's interesting but is it
proof no it's not but it is interesting
yeah so
uh what's the significance of all this
stuff oh yeah he's verified he's been
verified yeah on LinkedIn uh you can
verify if you have a email address
associated with the company got it uh so
now the next one is a dude named Josh
Rock who appeared in a Mr Beast video
published in April of last year
is that us Discord sound oh it's cuz I
open to message Aly sorry closed it uh
April of last year titled here it is um
$10,000 every day you survive in
prison so let me open it we can see
who's Josh every day so this is the guy
right here MH now in this one it's also
important to
note I'll show you guys the every day he
survives in this room I give him
$10,000 so here he doesn't say this is a
random person okay he admid that but if
you're a general viewer that is the
Assumption I that's that's what I would
put forward because it's it's kind of
you know the norm it's the expectation
yeah and so but here he you know he
doesn't say
it so this guy Sean uh this guy Josh
Rock here's his link profile says he's
been an editor for Mr Beast starting in
August so that's well after that's a few
months after here he
is yeah now should I I should note that
he also has lead editor listed there
without a time frame M and if you look
around on his socials it do it he
doesn't like directly say anything like
oh I got a job working for Mr Beast or
anything but he has a lot of tweets that
seem to indicate that he's working on Mr
Beast videos so he the video took place
in
April his employment officially started
on LinkedIn in August as as head of
editing okay specifically but but here
so if you go to a social media though
and you go back he's uh or if you go
back to November 28 2021 which is well
before he appeared in the video there is
some indication that they were already
working together as guys can see the
squid game in real life he said 100
million already with
eyeballs did you do the whole video or
just certain parts how does that work
with the editing team someone responded
so there yeah I mean that's there's
there's more it's like all of his
replies were like sick sick work my guy
smashing as always congrats man
incredbly proud of you definitely an
amazing accomplishment right yeah so
it's a so reasonable conclusion yeah
like seems like maybe he was just
working freelance at that point or
something I mean that was a you all
remember remember the squid games thing
there were probably a bunch of editors
that worked on that it was a massive
video so true true it's still real to be
Dam although I thank
you I will put forward though again just
to make some kind of assumption if I
just if
I perer perer worked on this I wouldn't
really be like that stoked you know what
I mean like yo we [__] did it 100
million like he's taking some pride in
and
this possible that's just obviously more
of a personal assumption that's an
assumption most definitely it is so here
so
basically that is um yeah we should uh
point out too that that guy is sort of
uh had been known previously to be um
the YouTuber Leon lush's YouTuber or
editor oh he used to appear in videos
with him a lot and stuff okay so so this
guy is a known editor for YouTubers
essentially which is what uh what's
important here so he has credentials
right so this is interesting I mean
there seems to be a how much does he win
how much does he win I don't know it
always depends it could be nothing it
could be half a million I mean let's see
oh he proposes let's see how much did he
win good only have the guitar and now I
need to start sacrificing actually ended
up watching the whole video is a great
video I
watched no genuinely it was pretty
interesting it was a good one I I for
the record watch all of his videos
and Teddy likes them now too so we watch
them together oh nice so to characterize
me as a beast hater is not
correct it's still real to be damage
exactly that's the last straw I just so
here felt good is this a check for a 100
Grand so how much did he get 340 so he
got 340,000 so that's a nice little
bonus you know what I mean mhm pretty
nice pretty nice not
bad that's a lot of money
um Al yeah so that's what we have on
Josh Rock again not concrete proof by
any means but it is interesting y
finally just stumbled Upon This by
happen chance and this happen chance
stance happen stance yeah I like
chance sure we we did this on happen
stance St we did this on happen chance
and this behind the scenes British
uh there's a British slaying happen
chance so you're just that's legit
that's what I was talking about what
were you talking about what happened I
don't know what either of you are
talking about doesn't matter fair
enough the happen
chance here comes the
queen what's a happen chance to see her
here
[Music]
today um
so here's the final one in this video
Behind the Scenes the VFX guy reveals
their team participated in a Mr Beast
video listen to this back in March Mr
Beast hit us up to talk about visual
effects we met at one of their sets and
actually ended up in the lambo video I
made a run for it but mik actually made
it to sixth and then Mr Beast posted the
Tik Tok you know the one it blew up
squid games so I mean he's explicitly
saying that he was in his videos right
so I like stumbled upon this cuz I was
uh I was interested in um uh seeing some
BTS to see if you could see the the
editor from the last one that we were
talking about in one of the videos and
was watching this and then the guy was
randomly like hey yeah I was in a Mr
Beast video so here here's something
that I think I should say as a beast
head and I've been watching for a long
time with all the original cast he used
to very frequently put them in the
videos to compete exactly and they would
win money all the time right so there is
precedent mhm however I do wonder if now
because that hasn't been the case the
the original crew hasn't been competing
for money in a long time that's you know
what I mean and I feel like things have
gotten way bigger than what it was back
then for sure dude this shit's so
crazy we got tried
that thought you weren't
eating keep talking to you
uh here I have something to say um here
is a one of the Stars uh la la yeah uh
talking she's a [__] liar first of
all she's such a liar go ahead read it
well laa Kent reveals how scripted
Vanderpump Rules actually is and her
thoughts so what what was scripted Dan
uh let's see and then the beginning I'm
trying to it's this [__] article it's
like broken up into separate pag are you
one of these guys that just reads
headlines listen I was just trying to
Vamp so that you could eat dude I got to
say side note watching that show I love
how Lala like didn't introduce who she
was talking to the whole time and kept
building him up as his big producer and
ended up being the dude who produced
gotty which is like the worst movie of
all time also he went to jail for being
I did he go to jail but he got like me
said he was like they refer to him as a
mini Harvey want with less power this
girl Lala is such a [__] character so
she not the most reputable daddy she's
not she had a secret boyfriend sugar
daddy cuz she was driving like expensive
cars and everyone's like what's going on
here and she's going on like mystery
yacht vacations everyone's like this
just makes no sense private jets private
jets so then it comes out she's getting
she's having a kid with this big time
Hollywood
producer who like a few years later gets
fully [__] me toe
yeah um so she you know
she's she's got her own issues Dan thank
you
though but anyway so I guess the
question basically
is here's the video question oh so here
okay so this is a problem if you go back
to the beginning of this video yeah he
says in this video Hold on let me pull
it
up that these are random people people
in a brand new L I grab 50 random people
in a brand new Lamborghini so I mean
that statement is not entirely accurate
right these these are not random people
at least one of them at least two of
them there was two from that team that
were in this video so and these are ones
that I'm sure because we've I'm not sure
I'm I'm assuming because we found three
and one of them we found by accident but
there's probably a lot more examples of
this kind of yeah uh fudging going on
you know another thing in Mr Beast
defense is is probably not n for him it
probably is but he has a lot of Need for
extras he need he needs a lot of bodies
you know
true so I you know it's it's it's an
interesting thing going on here yeah I
could see like with that Lambo video
they do get 50 random people 10
flake and we need 10 more people who's
around and they just grab these two guys
that are working on one of his other
videos or whatever and throw them in
there so then does he I just feel like
you're thinking about it as like just a
YouTuber making a video but he's way
bigger than that needs to be held to a
higher standard there's a lot of money
on the line if you're doing deal no
deal shout out how M out and you know
one and these contestants are coming up
I think how it works is there's ow I
think how it works there's people in the
audience and they call someone up to
play the
game if you found out one of these
people was Ho's friend
three times sep occas You' be like
that's a little [__] and this show is
way bigger than those shows is what
people don't understand right I know
he's just a guy and it's just YouTube
but it's actually way bigger 250 million
views that's a lot of views keep going
how many views is that keep talking
about how many views it is that so many
views man who gets views like that
there's really nobody else I mean even
as uh Peak PewDiePie was he getting 250
million views not even close yeah no
chance no chance at all absolutely
I'm but if you go to this one like an
example you said D let's say a few
people couldn't make it and he's like
guys you want to be in this video
they're like of course so should he not
say here's 50 random people or he should
just say here's 50
people I mean that doesn't to be fully
accurate yeah it doesn't really cost him
anything to say that mhm except there is
a very specific
insinuation with the random people that
these
are subscrib yo the chat you see what
the chat's PO out I see it I see what
they're saying I don't know what they're
talking you see look on the right side
of the frame uh near the yo it's
fot he's asleep again do you see itep
holy [__] hold on didn't see him I saw
the chat and I was like where I
recognize that glazed over expression
anywhere so I know he put out a new
video today called Hunger Games but in
real life and I can't wait to watch that
[Music]
I
they said it was a button I don't agree
oh my God I didn't think it was a button
but they said it was a
button I guess no I guess then yeah it
is a button it was a button went in
doubt just I I thought it was okay let's
just say you know if you had a time
machine you could have gone there and
being like no fous don't do it it's not
too late yeah there you go yeah don't go
to Japan much better way of structuring
that yeah statement yeah I may have
compared it
to don't do it again didn't say anything
violent the first time I feel like I
could say what I said and it's not as
bad yeah cuz you could you could talk to
that person when they're younger and
talk them out of it that's what I'm
saying yeah you don't have to kill that
person I just that's and I said this I
said this analogy is too overboard
granted stop it it is I said it's like
you know this analogy or this setting
people always say if you had a time
machine you could go back and kill Baby
Hitler would you do it now I'm not
saying that this is what we should do to
him we fully arrived back at where we
were no I didn't use the analogy no the
first time he didn't say h see I just
want to go and Shake him and be like
you're talking about time travel going
back and stopping then that's just what
I thought I don't want to do that and I
don't even have a time machine frankly
good so the whole premise is is faulty
yeah that's true it wouldn't be possible
yeah but uh that's not a fair analogy by
any means it's way over the
top
um watch just get a
strike oh God fidus bro what the [__]
you doing here
bro so that's I mean that's it that's
the Beast I'm curious it is an
interesting pattern in lie of what row
told us to to see all these other
instances of fudging exactly in the
context of everything get like one would
be nothing it would be nothing to report
right but now including row you've got
four curious instances of
fudging you know and I wonder now that
if people are looking for it or if
there's people that know of other ones
cuz like I said I think there's a good
chance that there's a lot more of these
could be I mean we just discovered one
now
live
rightand he's not a
random yeah and like I said it might
seem like uh pedric and they're saying
he actually won wait he won that okay so
I think that's how they met cuz I I know
his that was his whole story oh right
his origin ster okay so this is that
actually might not Mr be he legitimately
might have met Mr Beast wait I want to
see wi send me that which one was that
it was that car one the lambo one I gra
random people in a brand new lamb [__]
this needs to be studied by the car
let's see let's go to the very
end are you crying for real dude he is a
true competitor man he's taking that
Lambo all the way to [__] Japan baby
sign up for use the link in description
for only $15 a year it comes with nebula
for free which is basically a streaming
service that has
he's still driving
that sign for right
now oh God you're right what is
happening I'm pretty sure that was
pretty
unsafe I feel like if you post it on
Twitch you get banned MH you know what I
mean that video that popped up the
deadliest uh Laser Maze you seen that Mr
be video that thing was sick it's sick
AG So Co the people who conceive of
these ideas and execute them are insane
the next level talented the laser one
was sick I watched that one with Teddy
yeah yeah it's really cool all that
being said so what do you guys think uh
let's do a pull out was this is the
findings is the evidence interesting yes
or no that's all I
asked okay
also we got to do our ads oh what
yeah okay this is
encouraging
so 77% say it is interesting so we're
not wow only a quarter of our audience
totally thinks this is boring not
interesting at
all are you one of them Dan no I just
it's still because because it's a worded
so broadly it's kind of funny that like
one in four people in our audience like
no this isn't interesting all of the
show watching right now dude it's
honestly the law of PS I don't know what
it is you could say are you breathing
right now right are you a breathing
living sure I think most will be
no but there's always there's always the
detractors oh yes AB send me
that oh here he is talking most recently
on flagrant thank you AB you did great
job fishing this up thank you mey this
was actually oh this from a year ago so
relatively recent oh this is the one we
were just talking about with the dude
straight up is 25% say they are not
breathing it's the same result whoa
that's interesting oh now okay it's
shifting a little bit but it was 7525 on
are you breathing
can't I I feel like 75% plus is
basically a full blowout pole
wise so here this we we were just
watching this clip yeah and talking
about how he selects his girlfriends so
here it is by the way 18 million views
people watch whoa people listen yeah oh
my God no you jump skip me I took the
risk on this one you do it on the next
and I tried not to influence it too much
so like yeah how much you coach the
actual contestants I mean I was telling
them but they had the full authority to
do whatever they want so I'd be like hey
you should really go time's running out
and they be okay have you ever had that
where contestant just Bosch the video oh
all the time really it's annoying like
sometimes you'll give someone 100 Grand
and they'll just be like thanks and I'll
be like anything else you want to say
and Mr Beast when you fix someone's
Vision thanks is is that it you want to
give me a thumbnail or anything you got
any more and yeah could you cry maybe
come on give work with me I know like if
they don't say something please have a
dying mom please have a dying Mom it's
like it's more like anytime I upload a
video where someone's like doesn't freak
out people in the comments are like oh
it's fake and there's just all these
conspiracy theories and everyone's like
certain like if I won 100 Grand I
wouldn't react the only explanation for
why they wouldn't freak out is Mr Beast
P said not that this is an introvert or
anything that's why part of the uh wait
he said yeah I mean that he said what Mr
Beast what fakes it fak oh fakes it live
video they don't react I mean that's
kind of like a separate issue from
contestants he's Alex h yeah is there
Mor be much it okay
well thank
you his feet are not on the table by the
way yeah respectful King not yet anyway
where do when do they go on the he's
been
humbled it's towards the end it's start
okay yeah see here he's being
respectful when you go to the end wait
wait wait oh man when does he bring out
the does he not put up his feet eat
until like 3 hours into this because I
feel like that I know all about you
that's a problem for you no remember I
was defending the feet up cuz he was
kicking it with his boys by hour three
of a podcast you can put your feet up
your dogs at that point yeah I will say
he it changes the picture he's the only
one though yeah but I mean he's been
there for he's yeah three hours
Mr Mr Beast he test the waters too he
puts one foot up at first and then after
a little bit of time he'll put the
second foot up he was testing it out
reacted I think I think it's all good
yeah I think it's all good I'm
definitely not as upset when knowing
that it's after 3 hours of sitting there
right right maybe we've been too harsh
maybe on the Beast
possibility we love the
Beast and
um I would happily appear as a random
person in one of your
videos just let me
know
um so that's it that's it okay we have
got to thank some sponsors thank you
thank you thank you to our wonderful
illustrious well respected and fantastic
sponsors we love them guys thank you to
gamer
Subs hell yeah in this
cup is the last drink you'll ever need
why it's gamer Subs H3 podcast special
flavor Sigma brain the flavor spicy
Margarita is it spicy not at all it's
just a fun little tingle on your tongue
are you sensitive to spicy foods you
will not you will enjoy this
still guarantee if you're a never
Spicer you will still enjoy this and
that's my guarantee to
[Music]
you are you done with your yeah you
better take that way thank you we were
in the laboratory for months
years hold on
[Music]
month formulating the perfect one you
know when we first did it it was too
sweet it wasn't sour enough we're adding
we're adding we're working on
this and it is [__] perfect you guys
why is it the best drink first of all
got the it's enriched with vitamins and
electrolytes and all that good [__]
all different flavors it has caffeine in
it to give you a nice energizing
boost and it's super mega
hydrating no sugar great for weight loss
great for weight
maintenance there's no sugar and come on
sugar is the thing of the past it's out
we don't need that
anymore so this is it one more
time wow
he chugging it oh my God he
chugging badass no sugar it tastes
phenomenal oh man everybody loves gamer
Subs guys go to Gamers subs. and use the
code H3 to get 10% off your
order Gamers subs. G use the code H3 to
get 10% off your order this is the
official drink of the H3 podcast yep and
uh thank you everybody who uh is
supporting our gamer Subs uh
Journey thank you Journey oh that's a
little cup what's
that is that for babies what that's no
you're saying it's normalized love is
just a big boy I the [__] did you get
that that is so cute I'm jealous also I
should say there's there's also caffeine
free versions if you just want a great
tasting
beverage thank you thank you to gamer
subs thank you up next it's Shopify you
know them yeah you love them yeah there
is no better platform to start an
eCommerce business on period and
and Teddy fresh is on Shopify has been
since day one yep we've been through a
lot we made a lot of mistakes in our
business the one thing I look back and
I'm happy we did right
Shopify this week we switched our theme
it actually went live and nobody noticed
because it didn't matter to anybody
except on the back end
right no problems all smooth the thing
is you don't need you don't need to be a
slick computer programmer software
engineer
whatever it's built in a way that is
super accessible to Layman users mhm
they also have an
incredibly uh uh
useful add-on Store app app store which
some are free some are paid some are
reoccurring but these are run by
third-party really reputable good
companies so we have a lot of the third
party apps that we play monthly for like
a really useful survey they're also
really easy to um activate or cancel so
some of them we'll use for a specific
amount of time and then we'll say okay
we don't need it right now we'll cancel
it for a few months and then bring it
back yeah I feel like it's all so
intuitive right like we we just as an
example we have like
a a intelligent fraud detection uh
add-on so we I don't know what we pay
it's like $10 moreth I don't know but um
you we pay them uh monthly and they have
you know great support the product is
amazing
M everything so you know and then on the
other end if you want to get crazy with
uh programming and do something wild you
can also still do that you know what I
mean you can do
both um Shopify it's a global e-commerce
platform it helps at every stage of the
business from launching your online
shop to first real life store yeah they
have POS systems that connect your
online inventory if you do a popup you
can borrow the equipment from them
connect it to your shop it's super easy
also this is interesting and true
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading uh
Commerce
platforms also sell more with less
effort thanks to Shopify magic your AI
powered
Allstar have we used that is that new
must be I haven't heard of that
definitely want to get in on
that should yeah we're got to look into
that but I can't recommend it enough
whatever you're looking for you got Big
Dreams you just want to do a Etsy store
whatever please do it with
Shopify
capiche
um Powers 10% of all e-commerce in the
world
damn award-winning process MH sign up
for $1 per month trial period at
shopify.com after Dark that's all lower
cases one more time shopify.com
after
dark uh let's go let's grow that
business no matter what stage you're in
$1 per month trial shopify.com afterdark
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank
you love Shopify really do and finally
I'm going to keep this one going keep it
going I like it I want to thank our
final sponsor pet clad I've been talking
about these these pans are amazing I've
been I've been meaning to
brain we've had this probably for over a
year now mhm and I used this thing we
brought one fin
one I
um I use this thing weekly I'm scraping
it with
metal I'm smushing I'm slamming
everything you do I promise you right
now there's not one blemish on the pan
not one not a single scratch dude I've
never owned a pan where that's been true
mhm look at
that not a scratch dude I'm being
serious I'm being so serious right
[Music]
now yeah I it's all the pans I use at
home I love them you know
um they got this really cool uh
hexagonal pattern pattern that they put
on there that uh
is it's Cutting
Edge and you're not going to cut but
your edges will be not sharp when they
hit your hand here's Gordon Ramsey what
do you have to say I fell in love with
hex glads a few years back a chef friend
of mine sent me a 12 in nonstick pan as
a gift it was a joy to work with
something that I took to immediately as
a front runner in the industry they're
raising the bar my level of perfection
connects with that bar and more
importantly as a collaboration together
I think we will become one of the most
exciting brands on the
planet there it is uh he thank you Zach
didn't miss a
be it is um honestly for a really nice
highle pan it's very very well priced
pan uh you know hard kitchen Hardware is
expensive especially pans man if you go
to their
website such a great gift option by the
way I mean it's it is expensive gift
don't get me wrong like this whole six
piece set is 400 bucks
but I can't tell you how many sets of
pans we bought over the years that just
did not last Su no they didn't
last these things are spotless man I
will say we're not very gentle with our
pens no so we need something durable and
they also say that it doesn't scratch
even with like metal
utensils it says these pans are metal
utensil safe tough as Nails almost
indestructible okay well don't challenge
me
almost it's got the unmatchable Searing
power of the
hexclad it's
dishwashable and it's got a lifetime
warranty bro the last pan you will ever
buy built to last with a lifetime
warranty that lives up to that promise
so they're they really are putting their
money where their mouth is and I love
them for that hexclad we love
you
please uh find your Forever cookware at
hexclad and get 10% off at hexclad
docomo one more
time that's hexclad comom
sl3 for 10% off thank you to all of our
wonderful sponsors appreciate y'all
please support them if you're in the
market we love
them we do love
them Dan can you send me the link so I
can text
it okay one sec let me just grab this
dude I'm ready for the chocolate me too
it's dessert time should we start it
already um Sam cuz you you have some
no we got the guy coming no but it's
from we have chocolate from other spots
we have chocolate from another place I
don't want to eat it in front of him cuz
you know they they might be having a
blood Feud what are we doing here they
have competing chocolate brands in La
that Sam
bought we don't want to Chocolate cuck
him we don't want the chocolate right
now there there's
rivalry I can't appear like I'm biased
in this chocolate mhm I mean I think we
can get started I think so we can't
taste that want in front of him no I
don't even want him to know we did
it should we have someone on Lookout and
make sure he does not hear or see us Sam
bring out the chocolates please well
he's coming at he's coming at 3: yeah so
let's get started so we have a solid 24
minutes all right so um so this
chocolate holy [__] dude girl thank
[Music]
oh
Gabe Gabe
Gabe hey Ethan I miss
you I miss you Ean I miss you too
buddy how you doing I'm doing good Gabe
how have you been we haven't exchanged a
lot of words lately just keep being
positive you know feel good feel
positive that's
get is is is there good things happening
that's making you feel positive or you
just trying to you know keep your
spirits High keep my spirits High doing
my walk doing some exercise losing some
weight actually you look good I feel
like I can see it I feel change little
energy in myself [__] good job
[__] [__] yeah you look like you lost
some weight actually how much weight are
you
down I'm I'm down to 160 from what I was
like 195 like a couple months ago
been my ti walk the [__] am good for you
and so how what's your exercise your
power walking to Tower walk I go up this
hill like almost every day and then come
down the to walk is it miserable do you
hate doing
it um at first yes but once I get used
to it I'm looking forward to do it every
day really I just keep up the positive
myself I want to feel
good how long did it take before you're
like I don't hate I don't absolutely
hate doing this cuz that's where I
always get stuck with exercise I never
get over that a couple of weeks you know
couple
weeks and I I'm looking forward to doing
it every day I want to feel good you
know I want to get High Spirits on
myself [__] [__] yeah I feel good
[Applause]
nice
all right thank you Gabe nice to hear
from you buddy Gabe's on Cameo still you
can get your [__] babies there right
[Applause]
Gabe yeah
woo
yeah [__] yeah baby all right Gabe have
a great weekend we love you say hi to
nicknick hey nickn you what's on his
down there is a beer or
what oh Samuel Adams oh
[__]
hey all right y'all have a great weekend
okay guys have a good one [__]
bye by bye so um all right so basically
let me see what we've got here we're
there's
two gourmet chocolate places that we're
testing right Sam or is there more uh
two two so there
is so the where this this one's comp
patr and this one comes because of Sam
during this chocolate combo she said
actually I have an opinion as well she
is a huge fan of compat how do you say
compart compart how do you open this the
fun what does it say uh cream yeah that
different flavors just a Rubik's Cube
it's beautiful can I already say that
let me see like that oh [__] that's
it I never expected to have a chocolate
that opens like that so what's your
what's the story with these guys compost
choc well this is an Sons I actually no
this isn't ant Sons this is ant son
these are oh I don't want to try the ant
Sons yet these are compart okay okay um
so this one is I don't know if it's
Karis or
comparts uh but this is my favorite
chocolate on this one is my favorite
ever it has the o or whatever you call
that the the the Oxon o that that yeah
so I think that it's probably french
right okay so this this um brothers and
box is insane dude look at that so I'm
going to put this aside
though so this is your favorite
chocolate
ever yes specifically yeah the
strawberry one is crazy how did you
discover that uh this chocolate cuz I
don't ever think or know about these
Artisan chocolate places I had a friend
bring me that bar once before and it
changed my life and I buy it all the
time and so is this expensive um I think
they're $9 or $10 a bar that is pretty
expensive right yeah but it's worth it
just taste
it man I wish I brought the Swedish
chocolate so I see that you're into like
the fruity thing but let me see dark
chocolate and brown you know that sounds
like my kind of thing
M and
so how much was all this or the Box
specifically the ansons or the
compar this is like their Flagship thing
I'm assuming that one I think was like
40 I have the receipt I think it was
like 40 or 50 bucks that's Al that's
really expensive I
mean
[Music]
ch
wow I'm not blown away Ela is not blown
away I've never tried that one heila the
brownie okay you guys have bars do you
want do should we pass this around yeah
you can pass it around I'll come grab
it m I have dark chocolate in general
like a bar like this always at the house
I eat those like every day I like that
it's good
mhm I like
that here let me let me try the
strawberry is this a brand or is this an
artist in La
spot it's
a this is special let me look them
up I'm this strawberry one is so good
holy sh STW is amazing so wait where did
you buy it from I to go
Factory where's their
Factory so wait then who where do they
sell it to online
and oh okay so they're got it Sam Sam
told me she pulled up and was like I'm
such a big fan of you
guys what was their factory
look you could go back you can this one
has Oreos or here does that mic work
then or
whatever that's very good oh these are
all different flavor flavors you like
that one let me try that one all
different flavors I said that I
literally said
that their Factory wasn't anything like
crazy I was only allowed to go like into
a little certain area just to pick up
but did you see any orange uh little
people I do think that I I saw something
there was fishy business yeah yeah M
that one's good
yeah this box looks so
pretty with all the colors box of
chocolate they have like hundreds of
different types of bars that these are
just some that I thought sounded good
but they have a huge variety of bars
they're really creative flavors here
they are compartes lots of accolades on
mine I'm
seeing let me read about them is Oprah's
oist on there did you see the oist I see
G I'm wondering uh-uh oh no it is Oprah
on the right Oprah oh yo that's that's
her signature oh that's hers I think so
that's so arrogant
I'm inside the signature come on inside
the andon store they had a olist
plaque oh they got a plaque they had a
plaque on the wall okay hold on list I
just one of
these yeah I thought I
gotu but vanilla look different really
good really good
[Music]
mhm chocolate mocha you know I've
actually I've never tried their truffles
I've only ever tried their bars do we
have I didn't even well
those go for it grab one there's a whole
bunch of them here let me look at let me
see what what flavors we're working with
let me grab one
more we have a real life Oompa Loompa
coming in a few
[Music]
minutes don't call him that that's super
racist bro
Violet you're turning Violet just cuz
they're a minority doesn't mean you can
say whatever you want about them man
where's my Shoma give OA Loompa voices
now brown butter that's what I want
brown
[Music]
butter TR this brown butter brown brown
he pass around I want
toown
this you to see what they're eating no
they
don't
[Music]
compat chocolate here Los Angeles so
they are La
native dude they say here's how to eat
our chocolate here in Los
Angeles there's
a four-step instruction here in Los
Angeles number one anything out of the
ordinary yeah first enjoy the beautiful
shape and pattern of your kar's
chocolate truffle get ready for the
Perfect Blend of delicious flavors and
just the right amount of dark chocolate
on the outside I could could say I did
that two delicately take a bite of your
chocolate please note it is recommended
to taste the chocolate in at least two
bites let the first half of the Truffle
sit on your tongue as the creamy center
melts away three now Savor the flavor
and creaminess of the delicious interior
the delicately and perfectly balanced
signature chocolate mhm next four and
finally yeah take the second bite
having savored the first bite and
experienced the flavor profile through
delicate melting and exploration mhm you
can now fully grasp the Divine and
superlative taste experience popcorn
chocolate that's literally what they
wrote yeah I did grasp it it was very
good are you guys a Seas candy fan you
like that's see that's goat for me that
candy dude because it's such a great
present too dude it's I get so stoked
when someone gives anybody my peripheral
of SE candy I raid that [__] Sam how
what do you think about Seas candy and
compared to
this I think it's pretty good um it's
not my favorite but it's fine I think
you chocolate tears might
be experiencing these these flavors on a
different
level to me it doesn't cand to me c
candy is just not as artisanal maybe on
this level for sure it's not yeah but I
love it it's a classic see
[Music]
see see here's the Signature Collection
let me read you about them established
in La
1950 compartes is celebrated for its a
war-winning flavors and Unique Designs
our chocolates are handcrafted by small
team of
chocolateers using only the world's
freshest and finest ingredients
chocolate te mhm is that yeah you never
heard that chocolate tear huh yeah not
Oompa Loompa
can you I wish I button that up oh we
have a a true chocolate here
arriving uh it's they say they're deeply
rooted in Los Angeles culture a bite of
compartes
chocolate what CH I was so
sorry speaking out loud I said chocolate
here son could Bea
looma it happens just going through it
so um
deeply rooted in Los Angeles culture a
bite of compart chocolate transports you
to dazzling California Sunset and
magical palm trees oh maybe if I was
outside of
La I would be being more transported
mhm you're you're you're skeptical Dan
I'm I feel the hater's eye upon
[Laughter]
me um well clearly you're not going to
be enjoying the warm summer night that
it will transport you
to one piece is 60 calories is that a
lot or a little one piece that's pretty
D kind of a lot that's pretty heavy duty
that's kind of a
lot for chocolate I don't know I just
feel like seem one it's so good that I
want to eat like five well that's the
thing I think gourmet chocolate you're
assumed to just eat a little bit I don't
think I could slam five of those we're
about to when we get to endon right
I got a lot of questions for the Anson
guy first of all about the name of his
damn chocolate place and what where is
the father or the mother where's the
parents yeah he must have done something
bad what did you guys like the Truffle
did you all try
it good sorry like little
pieces I feel like it's so hit or miss
always when you eat those pieces right
cuz I didn't see what what it was I did
like it though sweet sweet honestly my
review is like how much did you spend
spend on all this
Sam um Al together maybe like 120 bucks
That's not including Anson right oh no
uh excluding Anson yeah yeah yeah it's
expensive I mean so it was 120 for this
excluding Anson no I think all of this
together was like a hundred bucks for
the compis and then for the ANS like 65
so it was 100 bucks see that mean that
wow I'm going to say this okay I'm going
to say
this I think a lot of what I'm tasting
here is too
sweet taste this one and tell me do you
think it's too sweet well that's it's a
cinnamon toast dude they're talking
about Perfect Balance you've become a
cinamon toast you I wouldn't buy it
personally cuz I'm not cinnamon I did
try it did you think it was too sugary I
think it's good for cinnamon toast
flavor if you're a cinnamon toast kind
of person yeah I'm a dark chocolate
purist M I don't like fruits in it I
don't like cinnamon in it I don't like
raspberries in it and blueberries if
we're doing a chocolate taste test what
I would like is for every chocolate here
to put forward their best
bar of dark chocolate right to feel to
experience maybe he's going to bring
that because I had the dark chocolate
from this place I was not impressed that
was the brownie one though right wasn't
it was dark chocolate and brownie so
it's not exact a pure it tastes just
like a dark chocolate though Brown I
don't know if I'm missing something but
it doesn't sound
that it doesn't taste that
different I thought the truffles were
really good and I the one that Sam
really likes was did feel special a box
of seeds I think is like 30 bucks oh so
seeds is so that's half the price of
this that's really expensive though no
for chocolate absolutely but this is 60
bucks the Box alone is really Beau
beautiful handwritten by the way 24
piece chocolate box best to enjoy within
days do not refrigerate M
Chocolates and it has the product ID
number and the lot number written in
pencil Ela that's accountability wow
yeah it's like a work of art that's
accountability can we get to trying this
one I'm dying I want to wait for him I'm
dying no he he should be here any minute
but I want to be able to express my
honest opinion and tell you if it's
better or not well just give the
audience the heads up right now you may
you may be lying I don't know it's
horrible all right go ahead try how am I
going to say to his face this is not as
good how all right so Anson we're
opening it
up I got to say though some of the
cheaper chocolate
Styles like around five bucks is or even
less can hit so [__] hard wa look at
these oh my God it's
beautiful oh [__] these are work of art
wait each one is oh no it's not plastic
that's the chocolate holy smokes this
this is beautiful yes oh my God is that
Jade they have this finish of like a
bowling Bowl you know how like they oh I
think he's is he here no can we get a
close-up cuz I feel like you have to see
you guys got to see how pretty this is
yeah one sec SEC that was that was a
spectacular
open um I'm going to try one of these
let's see so they
[Music]
are M interesting flavors too I got a
fruity one I don't like fruy uh we have
a $100 donation from Rich Lux who said
life is like a box of chocolates Rich Lu
life is like a box of that's so true
that's so true Rick we love Rick with
left this the Chocolate Factory I
thought dude I thought this was covered
in plastic that is literally just the
chocolate the colors are beautiful let's
try buy
[Music]
it
wo that is a unique chocolate experience
eating is like for the people try that
that is a unique chocolate experience
M that's that's
interesting wow here try this D wait
you're this is the answer sucks he's
bringing a lot Ela wanted to give her
honest I need to be honest but so far
that's not going to be a problem here
try this I think that's the same this is
a whole level switch me switch me this
is a whole another level
oh the whole dude I just read four steps
had didn't eat it you just put the whole
thing
in it's crazy dancing is that crazy
D I just you know what I mean I just did
like a whole
[__]
tutorial holy [__] that's special though
right what does it taste
like M I can't words don't describe
that come I'll pass it around do you
find that they're a bit too big cuz I
there seems to be similar size I wanted
half and so beautiful I don't want to
work they said you're supposed to eat
half yeah two bites I suppose but I'd
rather have two different flavors
if that makes sense but that's four
bites see that's my issue I want have
two bites of different these are the
best that's what you're supposed to do
she was right wait hold on hold on what
are you talking about I'm saying I'd
rather them be tiny so I can take one
tiny you can share it with EA you can
take half you want two bites of the same
flavor I'm I'm not going to put back
half of the e one in the sometimes I do
cut it with a knife yeah so that we can
all share I do do that at home sometimes
this is the best she was right I just
mean Anton I can can I try this one this
is the green one this is the maple
caramelized Peong there's different
layers different textures oh
[__] oh
[Music]
[__] holy [__] dude you guys try these P
these around she was not making that up
[__] me right you have to pretend like
we didn't do this when he gets here we
all have to why now I can even be more
excited we're gonna hype we're gonna
glaze them up try the domes I had one of
the um square ones and I it had fruit in
it not a fan of the fruits try that
though the the chocolate's really
delicate I'm not a fan of for either but
okay you know you know what you like but
try the domes those ones are
stunning
delicate it's a voyage of chocolate that
Dome Ethan do you have a little guide of
what's what up there yes give them this
all we have is this one there's a
gentleman it's not right it's not saying
what everything is I'll be here soon
this is the guide on the domes oh wait
wait wait I think this maybe tell me
tell me what color you have hold it up
I'll tell you yes so there is a
guide oh see this would be good uh oh
dark chocolate that's what I wanted I
want that white white with like
yellow white with yellow so that's the
passion fruit caramel oh my God the
would go crazy Brazilian passion fruit
and salted butter ganache just eat that
one that's probably the green one huh
it's yellow yellow with brown Speckles
what the green one can I can you show
Zach oh my
[Music]
God whoa that tastes like Christmas in
your
mouth it seems like all the other square
ones are bomb I somehow pulled the
orange the orange Mar one that needs to
be removed from any like raspberry and
chocolate I'm going to have to talk to
him about that disgusting what is the
green and brown the green and brown one
is I believe the pine nut praline oh you
show when they hold on hold on Ian yeah
go ahead might slam that what about the
red and
brown the cranberry hazelnut
cookie no I think it's this uh no green
and
I don't know should I do the I love pine
nuts but this is what the box looks like
I think oh he's here yep hide the candy
hide the candy hide everything hide
everything these are that were in there
wait Sam disappear
the yeah get rid of this compartment get
rid of all the all the [__] I'm
going to tell them straight up dude this
this this chocolate is no impressed col
cream you know they're all different
flavors I I these These are nobody do
you understand what I'm saying like
they're you you call call yourselves
chocolateers you be smech the the
[__] craft
chocolates these are crazy right wait I
want to try another one of these square
ones that yellow one was the most
amazing thing I've ever had oh the
yellow who had the other yellow one I
think you had it didn't you no here I'm
going to try this dark chocolate one so
to explain to the viewers there's the
hard
what
what yeah here
that's the dark chocolate Madagascar
dark chocolate
Gano mhm Baba
ganache so there's like a hard crispy
layer on the outside on the top there's
a little bit of a like a caramel SMY
flavor and then underneath that there is
like a soft chocolate honest such a cool
mix it's the delicacy of the flavors
texture yeah really it's crazy that dark
chocolate one was amazing there 's
another one that's what I dream every
chocolate would be holy smok Chocolat
does anyone want more I guess we should
wait uh you want more here I love it
here about bring it to you maybe I'll go
bathro before you I one no damn did you
try it I don't have hold on hold on go
ahead show love
Ian which one you got there what color
is
it that's the Hibiscus honey
M biscus honey
oh that's very weird is it a is it a
fruity texture like a jelly yeah all
different I'm out on those no offense to
Anson I'm just not a jelly guy
okay I don't know
I it's pretty good though no it's
actually very good cam you got some in
front of you yeah which one should I get
who else got the green one pine nut one
which one do you just pick one I'll tell
you what's in it
that one was so
good what the hell yo I guess that's
messed up man what the [__] we're just
it's all in good fun I'm eating
now what is this one what is this what
is happening back there put am I do what
is what is it just
plain I think that's the PB and J mle
levels oh that one that's hazelnut
that's hazelnut G gja oh no don't eat
that man that's the hazelnut the acid
one
bro
don't dude you just took the most acid
ever seen in my life that's it bro this
is [__] awesome this is really good
try one of the domes I I I have one
right here is it this go ahead oh so
okay perfect Dome is that does it have
brown Speckles no that's the pumpkin
vanilla marshmallow dud smells like
pumpkin that's what it was pumpkin
vanilla marshmallow wait that's the one
I had that's [__] Next Level bro
let's
try m
M it's so Mosey moosey yeah look at the
layers I Love Lucy oh that's good that's
a good view that was yeah that was
perfect wow did anyone else not try some
AB I tried it no it was great yeah I was
walking around passing him out but it
was good Dan you can bring him on he can
come on whenever he's ready if he's
waiting for me he just walked up I I
feel cringe but there's such a complex
flavor profile it start sweet then it
like kind of melts into the flavor
whatever it's the thing is when we tried
that compartes [__] I was like is
this really what good like Artisan
chocolate is yeah and then when I tried
this then I understood I'm glad we this
is arry this is
craftsmanship this is
tradition this is
Legacy
hello you want to uh yeah that's a good
spot yeah please join us hello Violet
you're turning Violet Violet we are
joined Now
by and Sons himself which one are you
and or
Sons I'm uh and with these mics you got
to get right up you can you can move it
towards you if you want okay yeah so you
are um have you ever been on a in front
yeah probably out of sorts you you
emailed us how' you find that we were
talking well yeah thank
you um yeah this is wild I mean like a
day all due respect had no idea what
what was going on here right yeah um
although I have you've been doing this a
long time I I definitely recognize you
but um so yeah out of the blue I got an
email from a guy who's like hey somebody
was talking about you on this H3
podcast I'm like okay what's that let me
find
out and he sent me the link to the
YouTube video and um right and then I
saw IID dig crystals was on here talking
about it you know about ID dig crystals
she's a huge fan she yeah so she loves
our stuff I've actually never met her
but she did this amazing like you know
um sort of taste test yeah and she
really kind of loved our stuff she's
been yeah she's been great she wonderful
we're all we all love uh Emerald Emerald
yeah so yeah and then so yeah she did
this comparison and and then she she
really Raves about us I I I excited to
meet her sometime so the name is and
Sons what are we doing here what what
and what um so so so it's an Sons
because basically this is a business
that um my mom started a while ago and
then um my brother and I took it over
and we thought it would be fun to kind
of update it and um basically just make
it a little bit more relevant
contemporary and so we we started
calling it and Sons and then how does
your mom feel about being removed from
the Legacy she's good she's like she's
she is very happy to be doing other
things and like enjoy you know enjoy her
life so she she ran a chocolate business
for many years and
um
sorry and then uh
and then yeah we we kind of took it over
and and been doing this so how do you
become a chocolate here yeah so how do
you learned right right you know so I so
we have an amazing pastry chef who is
part of our team who who who makes this
all who makes this all happen so Chef
Sandy um she joined our team and she's
basically she was the former executive
pastry chef at The French Laundry which
is you know yeah which is an amazing
restaurant in uh Napa and we got
connected with her and so it's really
the three of us my brother her and I um
you know um coming up with these
creations and um so and do you guys love
art because I feel like even the Box
itself looks like a piece of art yeah
yeah did we do do you how do you design
something like this like do you work
with like a third party marketing so we
actually I we have a few different like
designs that we do um this is not a paid
sponsorship
um and yeah so we came up I mean my
brother and I really wanted to update
not just the what's inside the box but
the Box itself a lot of you know
chocolate boxes you see and they're kind
of like brown traditional stuff and I
think when we were thinking about it and
this speaks to the name and Sons it's
really okay what is like the next you
know the next generation of of chocolate
feel like look like taste like and so we
wanted to really kind of you know clear
the slate and and try something new and
so the packaging we spent a lot of time
think think about the packaging um and
and you know doing something that was
was different so would you consider
yourself to be a choler yeah yeah so
wear chocolate here yeah and is
a one of the uh one of the one of the
last great Craftsmen uh that still you
know work with their hands yeah did do
you work with what is it what does a
chocolate here do I imagine somebody
with like a big thing of chocolate
melting like flowing chocolate and you
just do like this kind of thing what is
that what's going on there you know like
you have like
a you have a rack of chocolate for Gan
and then you you take the the flowing
chocolate and you you know you pull it
over oh and it layers it that's what I
that's what chocolate earing is Reas I
know what you mean yeah you don't know
I've seen that on behind the scenes
things is that what you do uh yeah so
actually so Chate there's there's a
whole bunch of different methods um and
techniques um and how to make it and so
each piece sort of has a different a
different process um and we should also
have Chef Sandy come on and she can like
really get into all the details but we
make both sort of a traditional line and
a modern line if you've got the box you
you can you can see both and they each
sort of go through a very different
process um of making it
there's I'm not there's not this there's
like but there's more like you know it
getting uh en robed sort of like on a on
a like a little conveyor belt I mean
everybody SE I lovec and then how do we
so there's not this so it's more like
this yeah
yeah we should you should come you
should come to the kitchen and they
should I mean we should make some yeah
that sounds like a potentially fun thing
yeah uh I most people don't allow me in
their kitchens and for good reason
but I'll disclose that to you later um
I'll I'll you'll be happy to know he's
the chef in our house oh yeah I don't
know what okay why I have
never stop you're embarrassing
me um you'll be happy to know you know
about this brand compart compartes MH
yeah do you know those people no okay so
if I say their their chocolate [__]
sucks you won't care it won't look badly
on you cuz we tried that [__] right
before you got here and that [__]
sucks like I didn't I'm sorry to hear
maybe I'm being harsh but the no it was
okay it was okay but it wasn't special
yeah well I was disappointed cuz like is
this really what Artisan Cho is but then
we opened this mhhm yeah and um the one
that really there's a lot missing there
there's a lot what happened yeah we well
we've all been eating yeah okay but uh
this one really these modern ones yeah
yeah yeah are those are really great can
I can I give you guys a recommendation
please I know it may not be my place but
no the ones with the fruit inside no go
really you can pH those orange marmalade
he didn't like orange marmalade but
yeah okay this is amazing we're going to
stop selling that right away I'm I'm
going to make a call and I'm going to
say let's remove every orange marmalade
from the that the one with the Jelly
inside that one done too just give me
your list we'll just remove them and I
got to call I should call it we'll call
up the customers and be like wait don't
eat those pull that out send it we'll
send it here yeah let me ask you though
good night can I make a box with you I
have
like I have an idea oh yeah I love
chocolate we're taking over your
business yes perfect it's our business
now yeah great I love chocolate and Sons
and us I dark chocolate and I don't want
anything in it but I want it to be like
you kind of feel like almost like you're
about to die when you put it in your
mouth very like we have chocolate we
have one of those yeah so I also brought
some samples for everybody and we can
try I was going to like you know we
we'll do a little tasting you tell me
when you want to do that I want to ask
though um just to talk about the fruit
one a little more because I am serious
about
this I feel like the major the vast
majority of people when they're enjoying
a box of chocolates like this when they
hit the fruit one it's almost Universal
disappointment so there's other people
though that love fruit so I this is like
a point of contention your own box know
some people love fruit and chocolate and
other people are like no other people
like no nuts you know well we can
actually let's pull the
audience should can do a pull I'll put
it this way yeah is this a good pull
should the
fruit jelly chocolates be removed or do
you like fruit let's do this do you like
fruit jelly chocolate do you like fruit
SL jelly do you like well do you like
and chocolate fruit and
chocolate I'm not I'm not coming I'm not
I'm not coming even down that that in
the chocolate I'm specifically talking
about these damn jellies the truffles
with the I'm doing do you like fruit SL
jelly chocolate yes or no I didn't you
didn't need to do the slash that made it
a bad point okay I'm going to remove the
slash I haven't put it up yet okay good
so read it do you like fruit jelly
chocolate perfect yes or
no do you have a prediction before we I
think it's going to be the yeah don't
look at the wide majority is going to be
no so you think like 20% will say yes 20
to 30% will say yes in my opinion you a
prediction I don't I mean I don't but
the other thing like a lot of people
come in and they're like oh you know I
don't like this I don't like that and
then they try it and they're like you
know what this is good so that wasn't my
experience no that wasn't yours but I've
got some other ones so we'll try it and
maybe you know okay I'll try it Z what
were you going to say the uh I'm with
you on the fruit and chocolate thing I I
hate it the spice pear caramel one was
the greatest thing I've ever had in my
life but was it jelly no it wasn't jelly
yeah so not all of them are jelly so it
really each one has a different I'm
being specific about the jelly so we
have a PB&J oh what was that I think but
that's got jelly so I don't know
interesting we won't let you taste that
one that one so here's a pretty good
results six the votes are coming in um
no has it although by a Slimmer majority
than I thought 55% say no so that's a
lot of yeses 45% say yes I think the the
FR people are maybe just a little slower
in the they they'll catch up they're
busy eating their fruit jelly they don't
have time to get to a pole that is close
to
50/50 it really is close and love you
said you like the jelly yeah I enjoyed
the I don't know which one I was but
yeah Big of the jelly yeah interesting
well let's go ahead and do some taste
test yeah
okay here's here's T J here uh well
we've got the PB and J in here too I'll
let I'll take yeah you can take the lead
here can
yeah so guys
um once again not sponsored but I do
think we're probably going to be taking
a stake in the
[Applause]
business so we're passing around these
are some of the modern oh beautiful wow
beautiful
stunning every everybody gets one and
then we'll go on a chocolate Odyssey
yeah that's what we can do and we'll
line them up and we'll do them by one
what do you think amazing I have to by
the way a lot of people who aren't like
Savvy with online would never think to
reach out and do this you R it out so
quickly and I I got to say it's pretty
impressive because obviously a lot of
people are going to uh probably go buy
your chocolate after this well great but
but I got to say um well I got to I mean
you were on it I well I I got to give a
shout out to Stephen Bruce who who
reached out and he's like hey you should
you should talk to these guys and he
gave me Dan's email and I thought
thought it was like the wrong you know
I'm like this email looks a little funky
there's a few too many h3s in there oh
yeah right and then uh sent it straight
to Dan right the executive producer here
we are um okay so everybody's got their
their their
samples Juiced up ju up the colorful
finish on those domes is so beautiful
yeah thank
you so where do we begin so let's begin
I'm gonna do the order that
I stunning we have a suggest we have a
blue one okay so the first one we'll do
is this one the one with the dark it's
got It's got a little cacao nib on the
top the dark one yeah is that what we
call it cow nib caca nib yeah oh CAC nib
and then the next one is got a little
gold leaf on the top we'll do that one
yep then the next one is the the milk
Square then this light blue mhm then
this one with the three circles and then
the yellow do you have a CH a a tongue
for like chocolate quality is that
something you're passionate about like
in your in your off free time in my free
time yeah you do chocolate I have a I
have a p yeah no I mean I love I love
eating chocolate so you know it's a part
of a is there other brands that inspired
you or like wow these people incredible
things with chocolate yeah I mean
there's plenty of great chocolateers out
there there's also great chocolate
makers so you know there's a there's a
distinction that I think a lot of people
think oh you you make chocolate and they
think of like a bar you go to the
supermarket and those are like chocolate
bars and th those are that's usually
just like a piece of solid chocolate and
what we're doing as a choler is really
taking all these ingredients putting
them together in you know really a
unique a perfect bite yeah perfect more
artistic expression yeah yeah and it and
it's just and it's just different I mean
we work there's some great chocolate
makers like dandelion they're in San
Francisco they're pretty well known here
in La there's letter press which is also
great and those are bean to Bar makers
so they're like taking the beans and
making it into into into bars and so
really what we do is just a different
type of specialty um as a chocolate here
it's taking all those I like to say it's
a little bit like a mixologist so do you
make the chocolate you use no so we
partner with different chocolate makers
okay so yeah so we'll use their
chocolate melt it down and then add
these other ingredients and how do you
melt it down did they give it to yous we
yeah we get them these little sort of
little pellets they're called fevs and
then we will put them into a tempering
machine which is like a large vat and
that both Heats it and then cools it and
it basically maintains it what's called
that temper and that allows um you know
Chef Sandy to to basically uh manipulate
it and add these other ingredients them
yeah she's making all these yeah yeah so
we have a whole crew yeah she makes all
of these yeah yeah she worked a lot yeah
so these are all handmade I mean this is
is really you know we do a very
specialized uh product and you know I
think a lot of people think of fine
chocolate um and a lot of it's like mass
produced you know and it's got that's
what I there's got to be some level of
mass production I assume yeah out of the
like mass production ones in the grocery
store what would be your favorite that's
a good question I just I don't you know
I much prefer to try like small makers I
mean it's much more interesting
Hershey's you don't bring get into your
house you there's just there's really
great stuff out there so what's your is
Hershey's as bad as people say they say
it tastes like vomit people I'm not from
here and when I first tasted it I was
like what is that well those those
companies also use a lot of uh
ingredients a lot of sugar so you're
really not getting typically you're not
actually getting that much chocolate
you're getting a lot of other stuff and
you know we're trying to really make an
impact with the flavors and and you know
each piece having its own distinct
profile let's let's get so this is and
if you have water it's always helpful so
just to have you know as a kind of
pallet cleanser we do more formal
tastings but let's just get into it you
do it in one bite yeah so this can be
one or two bites I think it's nice to do
one bite you can sort of see what's
going on inside you do you do one bite
sorry let's do two bites yeah we'll do
two bites I'm a two bite guy you're a
two bite yeah I respect the chocolate
too much all right so here we go this
one is what flavor so this is this has a
dark chocolate shell and then a milk um
ganache inside and it's got some cacao
nib as well for texture M damn so good
that's holy [__] yeah that's
crazy that's crazy this is a new one we
just came out with this people really
like it I love it I really like it when
was picking which flavors to Brak I'm
like we should definitely do this one
holy [__] it's a perfect amount of like
chewing on the
outside and then the creaminess inside
and the outside is perfectly thick
enough right to feel the crunch all
those all those little details really
matter so the shell the thickness the
texture you know what they call mouth
feel so like what's happening when you
eat it you know and then the cacao nib
gives it a little texture too that was
one of the best chocolates ever how do
you make that so you got the ganish the
ganach middle Baba
ganach you got the Baba
Gan that's actually just we we should do
Baba gan I mean you don't you might not
like jelly but what if we did Baba Gan
that pretty interesting and weird we
should do a box you should just come up
with a bunch of ideas and we'll just
do can we actually do
it yeah that we need to meet um I kind
of already want to call her Captain
Sandy yeah Captain Sandy below deck but
I love Captain I I don't know below a
boss oh she's a total boss she's a
badass yeah um so how's how do you make
it you got like a little dollet of
ganache so so each one of these so again
there's we have the traditional line and
the Modern Line and they're and they're
different and so like this is a good
example so this next one this is jindua
we'll talk about this one it's basically
Mage on a large sheet so they make these
large sheets and it's layered and you
can see they do the different layers is
this what you right and then and then
then we do this it's clip of that you
were doing this yeah what were you doing
it's this I think that I think he's
thinking about this one yeah okay so
right so but this one go it's on a large
sheet and then um they basically split
it uh they they make into smaller
squares um and it's get it gets cut into
these little they layer it right they
lay they layer it and then they slice it
into these little squares then on the
first one you had then this would go
through What's called the enrober and
then this basically goes on a conveyor
belt there's a a curtain of chocolate
Coco chocolate curtain chocolate curtain
so maybe that's what I I was I was
trying to reference the chocolate
curtain and that's just basically like a
waterfall of chocolate and then the the
piece goes through the machine and it
gets um you know enveloped in in the
chocolate what is cleaning a chocolate
curtain machine
like uh you really just keep it you just
keep it you never clean it no we do
clean it but the best thing is just to
to we just keep it R but how long do you
keep it going before it needs to be like
serviced we service them regularly you
know quarterly quarterly so it runs for
a whole quarter well no it's not con
it's we at night we turn it off I know
it's like a Willy Wonka's Chocolate Lake
kind of thing or what you can come you
can come and and you can do the cleaning
job so which flavor is this so the next
one is um jindua so jindua is is finely
ground
hazelnut so you've probably heard of
Nutella that's similar but that's got a
lot of yum um sugar and stuff um and
palm oil damn so um this is yeah sort of
a creamy hazelnut mhm very good
delicious no fruit here thoughts
Olivia's freaking out so Good Sam your
chocolate head what do you
think uh the chocolate gach one that I
just tried was super good that was crazy
that was like one of the best chocol I
ever had I think thank you
yeah you like that the ha text I have a
big Affinity with hazel
so yeah my hazel eyes let me see your
eyes you have Blues right yeah is there
or I don't know what's what's well cuz
if it has green would be Hazel it
wouldn't be
blue but uh I'll leave that between you
and your mom to decide that generally is
up to the mom um okay what's this one
okay so the next one this is PB&J oh I'm
wanting to I'm excited controversal who
doesn't love that's going to be
interesting I've never had total like as
a chocolate here's a problem bom it's
got the jelly it's got the jelly I know
and even though it's like
H it's like 30% jelly 60% peanut butter
I think you should still remove this
from don't listen to a mark from the box
that is incredible I'm not saying remove
the flavor really good though ignore him
completely but I'm saying I mean PB&J is
a class do you like a PB&J sandwich love
it but you just don't like when
chocolate gets in when chocolate Gets In
the Mix then you're it's no I'm not
saying don't make it because I
understand there's people that like the
jelly chocolate but what I am saying is
that don't put it in the rotation they
need to mind their own business in a
different uh part of the you know it's
so good yeah I don't I wasn't sure if I
was going to like it but I flavors are
great I have to start doing halfes now
cuz we've been eating a lot chocolate um
I'm trying to make sure I don't get uh
chocolated
out all right so now we've got these the
the the Modern Line yes right and these
really they just have a different form
factor but we're using the same
ingredients you know Sandy goes to the
the farmers market in Santa Monica I've
been with her and you know shop for
ingredients there really uh yeah we're
using organic Dairy so we're really
using oh these um kind of the best
ingredients that work the colors are
beautiful I mean so
delicate all right where do we go the
next one this is a sea salt caramel so
this is just a good this is kind of a
classic
combination chocolate for me
they should all be caramel no stop that
the only flavor oh my God now that's
busting oh my god wow so these usually
have a softer inside oh come
on what the caramel is more creamy than
usual yeah how do you achieve that so
s's really dialed this in I mean she
keeps updating and reformulating and
improving and she's you know continues
to Kind of Perfect this one this is a
great so it's a trade secret wow I'll
share it with you so that's the best
caramel I've ever
had yeah it's not really a recipe thing
though is it sure I mean it's a
combination of the recipe and the
execution mhm yeah right so if somebody
got your recipes like I don't know if
you watched Seinfeld have you seen The
Soup
Nazi um yeah a while ago so Elaine had a
beef with him and she got a hold of his
recipes and she put him out of business
do the recipes hold that much power over
your bus not with this there's no way
you could do that like as an amateur
that's what I think the technique it's
not right there's so much more than just
the recipe it's really bad the execution
I mean I think that's the case yeah so
what do we got next all right the next
one this is
s'mores this is also new yeah so this is
a classic combo I'm going to love this
um and so this is all the yeah all the
pie pie of a contain wow like a gram
cracker there's a gram cracker
absolutely and then s's seasoning the
the marshmallow as well so this has
really just a whole it's amazing yeah
wow that one's new that one's really
good that is so good wow any criticism
really cap no
notes come up with some sort of
criticism I will Zero notes the uh that
grand crack it's a little it's different
the consistency of it I wasn't expecting
that you know what Zach since uh in the
spirit of being fair and you are the
king of chocolate I agree it's a little
grainy it's soft that's exactly what
it's supposed to be you like it like
that pie crust I actually love I love
that I'm with you Zach right we actually
make it a lighter I mean I think it
works but I think it works oh it I mean
clearly it does work and Zach was the
one that offered the critique not me
all here butd right here I was just
trying to support
Zach and finally and the finally this is
a passion fruit
caramel so let's take a bite this is
going to have soft Center let's take a
bite and we're going to talk about this
one our boy a passion foot obsessed oh
[__] that one just breaks apart this
one's really soft so delicate wow and
I'm curious to hear how this falls into
your no fruit no it's not jelly oh right
it's not jelly this one's great you're
okay with fruit just a jelly you don't
like the texture or you don't like the
flavor
texture texture is really important
Place yeah that's so
cool this one's really popular our son
loves fashion food but I I love the
smell of it but it looks like nasty to
me and this is it is kind of gross I
don't tell him that but this is um
Perfection yeah he would love that wow
so and then we also have I only have a
couple of these but we brought these are
these little skulls we did oh
little is the flavoring something
special mer yeah it's Merry gold which
is um very unusual heavy someone get a
closeup or do you guys all have one no
here you want me and you to share is
this collectible should I eat it or
no yeah you should eat it here I want to
show up before I eat
it so how do you do this do you make a
mold yeah so we have a mold yeah and
then Sandy made a merry gold tea that
she um made for the
filling um
try but
and this one is pushing it pushing it
it's like right on the edge of being a
jelly
one it's not quite though very yummy
yeah oh yeah we should share
yeah m
I see what you mean
but it's almost like honey it is
yeah yeah yeah someone asked do you ship
to Syria we don't we mostly just ship in
the US you don't ship to Canada we we
can ship to Canada send us a send us a
DM and we'll you get a lot of orders
from Canada we do actually we do yeah
and so why you don't seem excited about
it yeah what what's wrong with Canada no
nothing I they're are Partners to the
north
there's a lot of good Canadians I'll
have you know they're not bad I love
Canada I love Canada no yeah um where's
the majority of your sales coming from
uh online sales yeah it's these days
it's mostly online so we have a store in
Beverly Hills um yeah and we've we've
had the same location for 40 years and
own it whoa the building no the the spot
cuz I yeah it's in a it's it's in a
building we don't know the building yeah
cuz know if you had a spot from 40 years
ago in Beverly Hills and good real
estate their rent's probably crazy there
yeah and uh so we've been there a long
time so we we we and we have a cafe
there so people come it's great people
watching we have a corner it's just
called anss yeah oh it's called an sons
and so yeah we're on that corner there
we have a cafe we do some really crazy
some great drinks in the cafe too um so
some of the chocolates we have a barista
a lead Barista there David and he'll
make drinks based on the chocolates oh
which is which is fun and then but most
of our business is shipping so yeah we
ship Nationwide and we ship you know
when we need to we ship with ice packs I
was just going to ask yeah so it's
really we we ship no problem people are
on your team cuz I don't know why but I
imagine that you guys were like a kind
of a big team if you're shipping you got
boxes making all we've got like uh 25
employees 25 yeah between and I would
imagine most of them are just doing like
Logistics and shipping of stuff like I
mean we have people that you know we've
got cooks that work with Sandy we got
fulfillment we got Baristas we have
salese ah yeah is it all being made
there at it's all it's all made actually
in in in um in La not at the not at the
shop yeah yeah yeah what's your brother
like
uh you introd yourself as number two
yeah why is that well I'm the second son
okay are there only two of you there's
two of us and then
yeah yeah no just fell an ey and so uh
what is number one I'm handsome he's um
he's cool he's he's great yeah what is
it like working with your brother it's
been great yeah I would I will a lot of
people like oh you know family business
how's that but it's actually we have an
amazing you know the three of us have an
amazing partnership relationship and we
all you know it's really nice we all
bring something different to the table
how long have you been in business with
your
brother um
maybe eight years something like that
wow yeah wonderful was it something you
always uh kind of knew was going to
happen that at some point you were going
to take over not really we were both
kind of doing our our our own our own
thing and then we you know we thought
let's this will be something you know
fun to work on together and we' never
worked together and so we said you know
let's take this on was this a big like
Capital risk for you guys when you put
this whole business together was there
like
a was Their Fear about the prospects of
creating a chocolate company that nobody
ate um not really I mean I think we had
a pretty good sense of growing up in the
business you know what what people are
looking for and what what what works and
um you know the response has been really
great people really like it I think the
hardest thing is really just getting the
word out I once they I mean as you guys
once you try it and see it and taste it
you're like oh this is really good it is
and I think just making people more
aware that there's really there's great
chocolate out there dude you I don't
know if you know this but you guys are
on Oprah's o list yeah I you know yeah
so she featured us she featured us last
year in for Valentine's Day which was
which was which was amazing when you get
a o list shout out how does that affect
your business yeah so that was
Valentine's Day that was a very specific
um program I don't know but we
definitely saw uh did something jum yeah
yeah but also in the New York time I
mean we've been we we've gotten some
great press and um yeah very luy um here
what how many so Oprah does the Atkins
right is that her thing the what the
Atkins diet Weight Watchers Weight
Watchers so how many points are your
chocolates on
weers I don't I don't I don't know this
is H this is on a day off okay I like
Oprah she's in she's doing the Weight
Watchers she's doing the chocolates
she's all over yeah um um is that when
you get on the olis is that like a a
publicist type of thing um or do they
reach out to you I I don't know how that
came about I know we sent them product
they tasted it and then they said hey we
want to include this I think they I
don't know if they discovered us or or
how that came about but yeah that was
last year Valentine's Day are you are we
going to be um we should add yeah we
should add yeah H3 we'll just should we
do it after Oprah yeah I mean you'll see
this is we crashed your website did you
yeah I'm just telling you that the I'm
not I'm not seeing any new followers
here well I don't know if they're going
to well chill and they're going to buy
the chocolate damn what more do you
want um nobody I'm telling you our fans
are going to go crazy for these
chocolates so you're probably going to
want to put us up and ahead of the New
York Times okay we'll do look why don't
we do New York Times H3 then Bon atite I
consider that
well I consider it a slight but I'll
take
it um is there was there more chocolates
that you wanted us to I mean we got we
got more I think you've we could do more
yes you want to keep you want to keep
going what I mean if there you have
different flavors yeah well you guys I
think you got the all different flavors
I think you got the the fall box yeah um
is it really crash the website let me
see let me see we we do that sometimes
we do do that sometimes and Sons oh no
it's open it's working yeah it's working
okay there you go yeah
Anson all right so
here's
more oh [__] I'm getting a call from uh
hold on someone's calling me should I
just take it
here hold
on hello hello uh I'm live right now do
you um I didn't wasn't expecting this
call oh okay do you want me to join oh
yeah let's do that then let's do that
yeah yeah you're good can you I yes
we'll do
that okay thank you thank you oh my
God yes of course of course this is so
beautiful thank you
yeah not exactly as I managed it going
but it's so
beautiful
sorry there's just something really
important came up here um here Dan I'm G
to send you the email then you can send
the link
okay there it
[Music]
is
um look at this what oh my god
dude I love color and this is just like
that's my language
can you show that I can't see because
the I just see the Instagram
page somebody Dan Dan can you take that
off our screen so we can
see thank you so which one of these
haven't we tried I don't know if I tried
the pink one so that's hibiscus honey oh
[__] no
comment it's jelly I'm being a little
dramatic
[Music]
oh this is awesome oh super cool for you
to come out and share this with us and
so yeah and we do so for the holidays
we're doing new flavors so you know uh
sy's got like I think five or six new
flavors for the holidays that we're
going be releasing we're also working
with an amazing artist so we love to
partner up with with artists so we're
working with an artist actually from vur
yeah there's this um artist Daniela and
Ventura and she did our holiday box okay
um and so that we'll be releasing and so
we keep you know kind of quarterly
update um keep things fresh yeah yeah
and we're always you know somebody wants
a if someone's like I love this one I
just want more of these they can they
order a box just yeah so in the shop you
can definitely come in and hand pack a
box um we don't really offer it on the
on the website oh you got so if you want
the hook up on the ganache come to the
come to the shop come in person
yeah I you can you can go ahead with it
Dan which is the G which one was the
ganach
[Applause]
one um so there's there's a few
different ones so in the bottom corner
there that's the dark ganache actually
if you like dark chocolate then that's
just that's just dark chocolate and then
the next one is just milk yeah that's
crazy that's insane oh I don't think you
had that one start so yeah I don't think
you guys so that's just that's just for
the people that really like dark
chocolate that's actually single origin
dark chocolate that we use um H yeah so
that's the best chocolate I've ever had
thank than best Sal thank you oh you
guys make bar wait oh no this is the
[__] [__]
compat cuz I imagine they're like a big
business right they're not Artisan like
you guys I you know I don't really know
too much about him let's see how many
people at work at compot trays I mean
you know you never know what you'll find
on
Google oh oer
owler CEO has a pretty decent rating
Jonathan Graham you know him I
don't I'll introduce
you oh they're
listed wait what the [__] they're on the
stock market oh so it's no no it says
private it says private independent
there
okay very stent 1950 okay very
good very
good let's see anon's website you want
to see Anson's website yeah sure Anson's
chocolate can I hear you say the name
how do you say it and Sons and Sons yeah
okay yeah there's our yeah there's our
shop does he know
that
[Music]
okay let me message
him he said he said ready when you are
just you can bring
him oh he's
[Music]
open
hello
hello is is this
sleep oh yeah this is sleep how are are
you uh who is
this this is
dream you have something to say to
me uh There's a
Nightmare you been you've been ripping
my
[__] I don't know what you're talking
about dude I made those tracks I I think
you no no you you you know what I'm
talking about you know exactly you've
been putting my music and remixing it
okay you hold on slow down there
dream these are serious
accusations first of all or maybe he
should wake up maybe it's time to wake
up dream dream this is serious
accusation okay I I the first time I saw
you singing that you were previewing it
in a live show right and it hadn't been
published yet okay that doesn't mean you
can rip it okay and then I took that's
[__] up hold on dream and I'm sorry to
break to you but IP law is pretty
[__] clear about this I took cuz you
had published it yet that's your fault
for doing it I stole no I sorry I didn't
mean to say that yeah you stole you
[__] up you [__] up yeah they're
going to be replaying that in the
[__] court case Ethan replaying that
otherwise known as s that Dan no there's
not going to be any court case because
when you put those sounds out sorry
about this uh sorry about this Jeff
right Mark
Mark you I mean I'm not good with names
but forgive me um the thing is when you
put it out there and then we used it uh
to create our own track then I've
already copyrighted it don't you
understand what I'm saying like it's
it's copyrighted originally by me what's
your what's your
copyright prove it it's just like it's
IP law like just you naturally have
copyright on your voice and your your
lyrics that's what you think I don't
think that you [__] up you [__] up
Ethan look look this is not going to go
like your last court
case yeah oh
that's then you're you're you're playing
it again you're playing it
again this is you you you've been warned
as
well God I love that song our song is so
good if you guys want to buy that on
iTunes for 99 cents the artist is sleep
and uh it's ours whatever whatever money
whatever money you've made from that
you're going to be giving me times a 100
when I sue you into the
ground okay dream
Cav unless you apologize right
[Music]
now seriously can I do it off why do you
no no you have to do it you have to look
into the camera and you have to say my
name is Ethan Klein
and I am not smarter than a fifth grader
and also I stole Dream
song nightm can we just negotiate on the
wording
exactly okay you don't have to say the
fifth grader thing but maybe you should
do it we have too many lawsuits going on
it's dream
scary a nightmare
nightmare I don't know man I just you
know I'm not big on apologies and maybe
let's just do maybe we can just talk
after the show you know you want the
clickbait of the fake YouTube apology
you want the clickbait
anyway that's kind of true that is a
pretty good point that's a goodl that's
a really good highlight Ethan of that is
a fire actually that is really smart
yeah uh Jeff what do you think should I
apologize who's Jeff who is Jeff I'm so
sorry I have I tell him tell him my name
thing he does have a problem with name
I'm dyslexic I just want you to know
it's not it's a nightmare look stop stop
playing it until until you have a
apologize you're playing it again Z stop
stop cut it off sorry I mean not I sorry
for playing it this time you're not yet
apologizing for the whole thing not yet
because uh Mark yeah apologies should I
apologize to to dream I I I have no idea
what's going on but let's we'll send him
a box of chocolate that'll that'll
that'll I'll oh that's a good idea
actually this is way too much to explain
right now I'll explain it to you after
okay hold on hold on would that smooth
things over if we sent you chocolate
it's not just chocolate it's the it's
like the best chocolate we ever had a
lot if if you send me a chocolate and a
Written Letter
apologizing what do you think Ethan okay
and then and then I can keep selling it
on iTunes
right for 10%
cut that could be nice that's not a bad
deal it's pretty good he's being pretty
generous here let's be you should take
it you know I just want to say that was
a remix that was fully original Ip and
artists have been gotten in really big
trouble for trying to press independent
musicians like like I am for quote
stealing their tracks I just want to
tell you that you know you're not
standing on the most Solid Ground
here well I don't I don't think you want
me to become your nightmare Ethan
oh
[Applause]
that's okay uh listen swallow your pride
Ethan stop dance stop okay
dream
yes I'm
sorry is this like an orchestal made
your song
Good
even cut the cut the cut the [__] cut
the music cut the music listen to me
listen to me look I'm going to give you
one more chance okay but now because
you've played an Orchestral Version
that's like a new version of the r i
don't even know how many versions do you
have you you need to send me the
chocolate and you have to apologize into
the camera otherwise you're done we may
be having run the fan competition for
the best dream remix is that a I don't
know if that's problem might be
happening next week are you [__]
kidding
me no unfortunately not how many
versions of it do you have but so like
you know how Oliver tree he does he said
I do like he does he gets one hit song
and then he makes like 200 versions of
it that's kind of like what I'm doing
with my dream hit I mean my sleep
hit all right I'm I'm going to apologize
I'm so
dream
first of
all thank you
for thank you first of all for putting
out that song it's not
out it's on iTunes right now no that's
not that's not my song oh he just
admitted when that's it we win GG we win
that well you tell you tell me Mark the
original Mark's a choler you can trust
your look look the original I just I I
did I just texted you the the actual
song it's unreleased though so don't
don't play the whole thing obviously
don't play the whole thing you say don't
play it on the show no don't don't play
the whole thing on the don't play the
whole thing don't play the whole thing
you can skip if you want to hear the
hook that I sung you can and that's no
no don't Ethan Ethan no no no no no
seriously seriously Ethan stop Ethan no
no stop was that
that's sounds amazing how do we know
that this is the real dream he just sent
me an ex an
exclusive that's true actually but I
can't see anything on the camera well
you can't see anywhere he's got a mask
on what are you going to see a mask yeah
yeah yeah can I play any of this you
could play the hook it's like 37 seconds
or 30 seconds 35 seconds in or something
it's that's the one you were playing the
nightmare the the one you keep hey why
are you making fun of yourself
I'm making I am making fun of myself but
I'm also making fun of you guys for
taking that clip it's always the worst
Clips I see on [__] Tik Tok no matter
what well I will say unironically that
song is for sure a [__] smash
Platinum we cannot stop singing it and
that is not a joke here is this
it oh there it
is
I can't sleep it's
nightm
nightm can I just
keep I'll just keep said the hook I mean
it sounds like the one that
we I will say maybe I'm a little mad
because your version is better so
you I'll split rev with you if you want
to sell
it and I can can I make merch that has
your face on it and says you know what
you know what I think that's only fair
that's only fair that play the original
for Mark I want to get his
[Applause]
face play yeah play his that where we
got the sound
from I can't sleep it's a nightmare a
nightmare this
okay he did a live show yeah and he I
actually wonder I don't remember which
show that was at I I did my my first
like I did six live shows my first time
singing in front of anyone and um
obviously I I think I did a pretty good
job but I don't know where this clip is
from but yeah this clip isn't isn't the
best but that was I was a capella
teaching it to the crowd like guys sing
with me so that's the context that's the
context Mark um I don't I think at the
time it was he was just kind of talking
to the audience and we were like oh this
these the way he said that sounds kind
of musical we'll sample that and do it
into a song so go ahead go ahead
Zach okay now that's
the and then this is the song we
make and I'm playing the guitar the and
the drums and the baby different track I
say and
singing
[Music]
go ahead Z you can Z so who's so who's
wrong well what what is Dre so dream
what what is what's what's the what's
the what's the issue like what's going
on yeah uh um he well see the with my
problem is that he's saying he's
sleep making F of me's adopted the name
sleep too oh we all know comedy is not
allowed on the [__] internet right
that's that's the biggest rule right and
if you do comedy you get
sued un unless you're sharing the money
so if he shares the money then fine
let's go poor apologizes because
everyone has an ego all right listen
Dream thank you for for talking to the
audience in a melodic way I didn't know
that it was going to be a song of yours
I just thought that it sounded good and
would sound cool in my own
track so
if I stepped on your toes
or if I in any way made it sound like I
was ripping you off or something I just
want to let you know that that was
definitely not ever Our intention and if
anything sounds it's me it's mostly a
coincidence that it even sounds like
your song but with all that being said
um I do apologize if you if you if you
felt offended at
any okay well see why' you have to add
that if you felt offended like you could
you could have just cut it off there and
it would have been a great apology you
made a lapse in your judgment a
terrible andever
one people don't believe it's
dream did you say you're streaming or no
yeah actually I am I am but I'm I'm on
my alt right now but I'm streaming oh
okay you're streaming to your alt do
people on your alt know that you're you
but you could by way I I feel bad now
this is going longer than I thought um
Mark yeah yeah I'm I'm sorry for inter
I was mid someone said someone said when
are you when are you releasing that song
I don't want to keep you here okay but
uh but you can also stay true all I I
mean I I kind of I'm invested I want to
hear how this I want to hear how this
like ends up like who's going to hang
around Marcus I'm also think you know
what I was thinking is you should
package them up like you should present
both like give dreams
version yeah do one of those version and
here's like here's here's dreams version
here's Ethan's version it's actually a
good suggestion yes yeah I mean I'm not
I'm not sure you know this Ethan but I'm
signed to Republic records so they might
you know [__] you up like
oh yeah well yeah who's that that like
the the Republic gonna even just who
mega Lo like Republic who is that funny
none of my
business who um are you streaming to an
ALT so do they know it's you or no yeah
no I mean I have I have viewer like a
lot of years right now I'm just I I I
stream on my when I was just what
happened was I got on and I was just
like practicing Minecraft and then
someone in chat said when are you
releasing panic attack and I was like
[__] Ethan texted me yesterday like oh
my God so I went to my text and then I
was like is it too late but
here so you have an alt and a main
streaming platform why do why do we make
the distinction so my ALT I usually just
stream like I don't talk usually I just
I'll just be like oh I just want to like
I'm just going to be practicing or
something so I don't want to and I'm
going to distracted so I'm not going to
talk with chat so I just I don't want to
make like a dumb stream on my so I my
that makes sense that makes sense I see
um so there you guys go here by the way
I have new merch for you dream okay just
just a suggestion I don't know if you
can see this but I'm thinking of selling
this wow okay as part of my new single
are we going to do a dream x uh [__] I
forgot what's what's your uh your you
don't you have a clothing line yes Teddy
frh thanks for car Teddy fresh there you
go yeah dream dream X Teddy fresh that's
the new merch let's
go so there you go I mean people don't
believe it I mean he's streaming right
now what do you want yeah herey wait can
I if I go on OBS and I start a virtual
cam let's see will this
work well this work let's see how do I
people are so confused in
[Laughter]
chat wa let's see if I turn my camera
on look there he is in Minecraft look
it's
it's proof
guys it's dream
everybody he's in
Minecraft yeah
great this is not helping convince
people probably not dream look my epic
skills will help
convince dream
um oh I are we thinking of moving on
from Minecraft ever or are we pretty
committed to that one um well I think
that uh like I my view on Minecraft like
it's such a big part of me I I started
literally when I was like 11 years old
and my first job my first like L my
first girlfriend I met on Minecraft like
everything pretty much in my life
started from Minecraft I learned how to
code because of Minecraft um I met all
my my roommates I live with right now in
Minecraft so like I view Minecraft in
such a positive way and I never I never
want to move on from it oh that's
actually really nice cont but then again
who who who knows I mean you never know
what where life takes you but right now
I have no plans I've been working just
as hard on Minecraft to have on anything
else even though my channel doesn't show
that but really you know why when
Minecraft was like in its Alpha I played
it for a little bit and I never came
back to it uh but I see the game is like
transformed into something crazy and uh
I I I relate because I I have super
nostalgic games like that too that I
think about all the time so yeah I mean
it's a Sandbox so because because it's
open it's you can pretty much do
anything you want in it so like I the
reason is I don't get bored of it is
because I've never played it the same
way like I went through even on my
YouTube channel I went through phas like
I started storytelling and then I went
into like um you know Mysteries and I
went into coding cool stuff and then I
went into like
uh you know speedr running and then I
went into professional like PVP it's
like there's so many different things
and like in that list there's not even
like building and and everything else
you can do in Minecraft so so are you
playing right now yeah no it's my it's
my brother actually oh it's not you no
I'm joking that's me I was just well
what what's funny about that I don't
know if you have a brother or not yeah
know it's it's just it's a common like
professional gamer joke I guess it's
mostly sexist made to girls but I made
it I made it about myself got it so is
what you're doing difficult it seems
like you're doing some interesting
jumping patterns oh no right now right
now I'm just running around distracting
myself but this parkour course is what I
was practicing so but it's not I can I
can actually play it but
not and and can your stream hear us or
is it muted yeah your stream can hear my
stream can hear you guys I didn't give
any I was like guys I'm about to put on
like a lore voice I'm about to be mean
trust me it's I'm I'm just I'm just
playing character don't worry and and
then I went in but I used to I mean they
used to it cuz I did did uh like we did
um dream S&P streams back then where I
was like the villain and so there was
there was like a year long where like
the only appearances I made on live
streams was me like being this horrible
like manipulative like terrible person
that was just like harassing other
streamers so so am I too old to play
Minecraft dream no no it's so funny
there was a there was a older lady that
was at multiple multiple of my concerts
that had like meet and greet tickets and
she was just a fan and um uh she she
just she was really cool she was like
talking to me about it saying like uh I
don't remember if I had to guess I'd say
she was like uh like 55 60 she came by
herself yeah she was just a fan concern
you at alls anything it didn't because
her reasoning was pretty good like she
said she was a before she was a fan of
me she was a fan of techno who would had
much more like mature humor than me I
guess um and then I think she she
probably partially got connected to me
through like his his passing and stuff
and and I made it I made that obviously
my the song um recently until tell of
dead that was about that so so are you
actually signed to Republic yeah yeah
okay I didn't tell them anything about
this so I I they have no wind of it yet
so you're you're safe for now
but all right just keep this between us
for yeah no I I won't mention it to them
for now you can get away with the iTunes
bro they don't need to know I mean
you're it's not even out you're not
going to make them any money with this
[__] yeah exactly no it's going to be a
flop anyway like they might as well just
give up on it what does it mean if they
sign you because you are inde you
already wealthy and have reach what does
a record label do for you if you already
have that kind of stuff yeah well I
think that the biggest thing is well one
I went in with a lot of like Leverage
and I think that um people that sign
record deals usually get like I think
most record deals are they they screw
like a lot of people get screwed like
artists get screwed from record deals um
but I went in with a lot of Leverage
because I already I already ran my own
merch I already did I already you know
had a following I already had you know
success successful songs Etc um but
really they just it's just like
connections and like uh knowhow like I
it's I'm I feel like Republic's very
good for like like I'm using them also
like a consulting firm or something like
hey how how should I do this or what's
the best way to do this how you know
what's the best way to maximize this and
there's a lot of things like my tour and
like um and my last release that just
would not have been possible to do
without them um but really they just
they help you get like playlisted and
they help you they help you get
connections to you know producers and
other artists and stuff Mark what are
your thoughts on
that Mark by the
way I'm
jeer
chocolate what do I think let's have an
introduction cuz I I I feel like I came
in and stole the spotlight and then now
now he's just been sitting there I want
I want to know who he is he's the
chocolate here literally we're sending
you a box to say to say to say sorry to
this okay to just to smooth things over
it's going to be a box of jelly it's
going to be a box of jelly
chocolate all the re the reg I like I
remember uh what's the there's there's a
really big company that does uh CH that
that sends CH that's like expensive
chocolates what is that company it's
like a oh Edible Arrangements um and I
remember the I didn't know what that
company was and and like uh someone sent
one to my house like ages ago and I
thought they I thought it was like weed
so I turned it away I was like no
Edibles like I don't know I don't want
Edibles it's like a rose that's Ed fruit
I think it's like fruit it's like cut
fruit they make like I do they do make
like cool flowers and and shapes and
stuff yeah yeah but I actually had
turned away my like roommates a birthday
gift so I didn't I didn't realize but
oops oopsies I'm noticing you're falling
a lot yeah well I'm not focusing and I'm
just I'm ADHD running around so that I
am failing a lot but and you're supposed
to be good at this game right look look
I have look okay I have the record on
this Forest right now so it's fine I'll
take it I'm just pring it anyway let me
see the let me see the
scoreboard and also three and four are
also three and four are also me they're
just me on my friends accounts so you
have a 4C lead can you yeah but the the
thing is is that this is all like big
YouTubers like this is from MCC so
they're all like ma massive people um
but uh the the course was open to
someone else who did it and they they
have a 26 second lead on me 26 second
it's just like a normal a normal like
player um and so I'm I'm trying to catch
up to that and like I've gotten a couple
runs that are really really close I just
haven't finished them out because I'm
trying to be like perfect so is he doing
[__] that like you don't even understand
or you know he's just perfect well the
the run like I watched his run cuz I
didn't even I didn't know about it until
like the other day and that's why I've
been playing this a lot but um when I
watched it I was like holy [__] it's
like robotic um but the thing is I feel
like out of every all of my Minecraft
skills like there's a lot of things like
people are like oh because I'm I'm very
like overrated I think that's that's the
case for almost every YouTuber because
they're like oh you're being compared to
other YouTubers and obviously YouTubers
don't have time to play Minecraft 10
hours a day or 20 hours a day or
whatever um but uh but like parkour is
probably my number one skill and so like
I genuinely think I'm one of the best
like parkour players in the world if I I
had time which is yeah which is what
this is It's just jumping around and
Mark he I don't know if you you are
talking to one of the top Parkour
Minecraft competitive I can tell no I
can tell I mean I'm very I'm very
impressed um this is a big deal it might
not look like it it's one of the best
chocolate chocolate guys yeah we're
we're on the same look dream dream you
and I on the same level you guys are at
the top of your game he actually is uh
he has a chocolate brand and Sons that
we're losing our mind we're just it
really is the best chocolate what's this
blue one and we wanted we wanted I
wanted we wanted do a giveaway oh yeah
your to your to your people that's
actually like a cookie butt that's
speculo yeah that one's really popular
too dude I've had so much fun know can I
buy can I buy like an ad spot on your
podcast how does that work for what I
don't know it just it would just be
funny like I actually I reached out a
while ago to like Mr Beast like this was
like a year and a half ago and I was
like can I buy an ad on your video and
he's like yeah if you pay like normal am
of Advertiser I was like H maybe I would
do that I never ended up doing it but
like I feel like it' just be funny like
maybe I would I'll I'll sponsor your
podcast you just want
I'll just be like guys my YouTube Chanel
my YouTube channel is whatever it's like
a 30 second ad you have to like
advertise my my YouTube or something or
like whatever it is I'm up to that week
you're like guys so last week Dream It's
like a dream update section of the of
the thing I mean I'll be I'll be honest
we need sponsor yeah we're desperate for
sponsor stream we
totally I'm actually down let's talk
about let's look it
up I think it be it just be funny I it
be like why the [__] are you advertising
dream like in the middle of your your
thing I don't I don't ask listen I don't
I don't ask questions if there's a check
involved I'll say whatever you want all
right cool you want me to deny the
Holocaust I'll do it what holy
[__] terrible terrible you you wouldn't
you didn't ask that for the record and
you would never and you I would I would
never ever ask that also terrible we're
Jewish so just to put that out there
she's act she's Israeli I'm from Israel
okay and I'm a yeah so the hoca allowed
to joke about the Holocaust is what he's
trying to say it's not funny though I
wanted to emphasize that and dream shame
on you for even oh my God I I didn't do
[__] what the [__] not no don't get me
canceled chill chill
chill you're G make like a clip dream
dream jokes about
Holocaust especially with like the state
of the world right
now right now dude you're doing it right
now you are I'm doing what you were
joking about the Holocaust it's no I'm
not no I'm
not okay fine Jesus it's just a joke as
soon as he said he wanted to be a
sponsor Ethan try to scare him
away's like you want to sponsor my
videos let's talk about the
Holocaust I was just saying I'll do
anything that was my
point you know I mean clearly I I saw
your ass on my Twitter like ages ago so
I think you probably would but was that
the one that was for free Theodore yeah
I gave that one out for free with our
son oh no that was the Kim Kardashian
one no no yeah it was in the mirror it
was the James Charles one oh the James
Charles yeah sorry about that it's okay
you've probably seen worse for me even
though it's not my
ass that's the thing as well is like I
post so much cringe stuff but I think
people people people outside my audience
don't realize that like I'm like I'm
very very like what's the I mean because
this is like such a not humble thing to
say but I'm very like uh self what's the
what's the word I'm looking for self
aware yeah I'm very self-aware I'm very
self-aware like I make fun of myself
more than anyone does like more than my
haters more than my fans my fans get mad
at me for like like you're too like B
hard on yourself I'm like it's just
funny to me like I I see stuff like you
know and I'll laugh about it um you know
what's not funny man I mean this jump is
not happening Brother oh yeah know I
should restart yeah no I can't I can't
parkour when I'm distracted it doesn't
work for
me what I'll do is as soon as you want
me off I'll stay on but I'll just mute
and then I'll do it and you can you can
see it in the background as okay
all right well listen um it's actually
really nice to connect with you yeah
maybe we can do a a longer format kind
of interview another time but just like
Mom's the Word okay on the on the um
Republic
stuff yeah okay you know if and if you
have if you get like hit with a season
toist or something just let me know and
you know we'll try and we'll try and
work it out okay yeah cuz they're not
they're not going to send that are they
no they shouldn't they shouldn't they've
been they've been very uh like I think
Republic's uh like been very good with
me and like listen to like hey you know
YouTubers and twitch streamers and stuff
like in regards to um copyright so okay
because just for the
record Ethan Klein's it's a stage name
and whatever address you see on the
internet or whatever it's definitely
super old so even if they try to serve
me there's no chance that they'll find
me okay so I just just want to make that
very clear I'll make sure to tell them
that if they if they ask me don't even
I'll say he's like anonymous online and
like no one he's like a ghost you know
no one knows who he is I was like
dream exactly do you regret taking the
mask off is that true or not I've heard
people say no that's that's the that's
the whole self-aware thing like the
whole video was a joke but the headline
just gets spread of like dream puts the
mask back on like the description got
spread and people were like there was so
many tweets and stuff saying like
there's so many tweets and stuff saying
like how horrible like like what a doof
like he he really got bullied in putting
the mask back on and then they're
showing pictures of the description
where I say guys I'm going to take a
break to fix my face like I'm sorry for
being ugly I'm like sitting there like
how can you read that and and take it
actually seriously and then you watch
the video and it's my two best friends
my roommates not like bursting out my
door and being like put the mask back on
you're ugly you know whatever I'm like
how how does that spread I think people
interesting I think the biggest thing is
that when you're like um like
villainized either for good reason or
for bad like I think there's plenty of
things I've gotten criticism for that
are totally legitimate and things that I
also haven't that that AR that aren't
legitimate um but regardless I think
people then are going are going to
assume that everything about you is
negative so they don't they're not going
to assume that I'm self aware because
they're going to assume that I'm just
being an idiot or that I'm being a loser
or that I'm being you know uh like I'm
looking for attention or whatever rather
than just you can you can think
someone's a bad person and then realize
like oh they have a couple good like
qualities about them like oh they're
they're funny or they have or or in this
case they're self-aware or they're like
oh this is a funny thing to make fun of
and Mark does that ring true to
you I would I was what's going on thank
you thank you
Mark yeah I mean I get that myself you
know but it's interesting because I talk
about politics and stuff so I understand
why people hate me on that regard but
you you just play Minecraft well I don't
just play Minecraft I think that the the
way that I the reason I became one so
controversial and then also so uh so
like I don't know just so as big as I
got was because I took the approach of
like oh I'm not just going to play
Minecraft like not not not talking about
the music front I'm talking about like I
decided I'm I'm going to be I'm going to
be like you know which became very
controversial like I'm going to be
closer with my audience like I'm going
to be more open with who I am and like
myself and I'm going to have
conversations I'm going to you know have
lots of more discussions and openness
and not even though I was faceless like
because I was faceless I I had to make
up with that make up for that by like
sharing so much more about me outside of
that like I share like people would be
like oh you're so secretive your faces
like no I'm so not secretive the only
thing that I keep secret is my face like
everyone knows everything about my life
and my struggles and everything else I
think that became because I was I was so
willing to be like a gamer that's like
emotional and like um in bad and good
like there was tons of times where I was
like aggressive in the wrong way I was
had an opinion that was that I ended up
changing that I was so stubborn on
because I'm a stubborn emotional person
um but I think that that that passion
made help me grow into like who I am now
and then also helped me grow like as a
Creator as well so I think that I think
it really was just that I'm so outspoken
about everything uh that it caused me a
lot of problems and then a lot of good
as well so when you took the mask off
was there anything where you're like oh
this [__] sucks like this is what I
was afraid of
happening no but I think that the
biggest thing is that people that that
talk about the whole face reveal and go
like oh you know talk about that he he's
ugly thing and stuff like don't realize
how small that was like they're like oh
it was number one on trending but the
trending system on Twitter the way it
works is if something's not tweeted
often that's what will get more trending
there was 7,000 tweets and the video had
like 50 million views in a day 7,000
tweets saying he's ugly like wow there
was also you know thousands thousands of
tweets saying uh you know positive
things whether it's like um you know
congratulations or like Dream Team
Meetup or um or like you know his hair
or things like that um and the the you
know the video comments I'd say were
probably like uh a lot of them were
obviously filtered but were probably
like you know 2080 or something like 20%
hate and 80% like positivity um and so I
actually I walked away from it like a
having a very like positive view I
actually hurt myself because I was like
in my socks and I ran like after the
first hour and I think it had like I
don't know 10 million views something
ridiculous in like one hour I like ran
into my kitchen um uh I yelled he's ugly
he's trending and slipped and like hit
myself on the on the floor in the
kitchen and it it was just my friends me
and I was joking I was like laughing
about it and thought it was funny like
people have such a a like nihilistic
viewpoint on it when I'm I look at it
and go like wow that was one of the my
favorite days of my life and it was it
was super positive and it was one of the
things where it was a culmination of
everything up to that point that I had
done I guess yeah so he he had never
shown his face okay he's a very popular
YouTuber okay and then one day he
decided to show his face and then on
Twitter the first it was immediately
trending that he's ugly just those words
yeah he's ugly was number one trending
on
Twitter put the mask back on was number
two I think thoughts on that
one night that's um not a great Trend
right yeah no all right dream thank you
so much we love you and uh go ahead Zach
play him off please no no no come
on thanks
buddy thank you I'm definitely gonna not
I'm definitely not going to do any more
of these songs okay yeah no more remixes
no more remixes promise we're not going
to have a whole show about it on um
Friday next week all right thank you
guys having me I'll I'll talk to you
about that sponsor it as well I actually
actually messaged me about that for real
seriously all right cool all right bye
guys bye bye I'm sorry about that that
was that was a that was quite a um
detour no that's okay yeah seems like
it's all goodness I don't know I I was
trying to play good with him but I
didn't really I didn't I felt like we
were at an impass cuz I wasn't really
I'm never going to [__]
stop you know but you guys seem
good yeah I I let him on a little
bit well um well this was [__]
awesome thanks yeah yeah thanks for
thanks for having me I'm happy that
uh you guys have made this this
beautiful product thanks I really appri
I'm going to have one more I so much
don't give me another half eat oh [__]
what's that one you're feeding um try
that that is a coffee I'll save oh yeah
I'm going to save it for later wow once
again uh and Son's chocolates yeah so
should we do a giveaway oh yeah what do
you want to do with the giveaway I don't
Dan Dan and I were talking I think the
easiest way to do it is um
maybe what we' do is like follow us on
Instagram like our what I was think do
like our most recent post and then the
the current post that we put up today
like it and then we'll give
away um at the end of the well like
maybe on Sunday we'll look all all the
tell me how many are you what are you
giving away we'll give away that box
that you're eating a 12 piece a 12 piece
box that's a good prize and what's the
what's the um MSRP on this bad boy uh
it's 49 Dam all right all right well
here's the account uh for people that
are wondering oh [__] why' I do that I
thought it was like a paper towel
oh and the latest post is this one this
is the one right do they need to follow
you yeah so how do so yeah follow us and
like this post and then we'll pick a WN
we'll pick there going to be a
commission involed a winner yeah sure
we'll pick a winner on
Sunday
um we're going to pick a Wi on pick we
why don't we do we'll do a we'll do five
boxes we'll give away five boxes we'll
pick five people at random that that
follow us and like that that that post
does that sound like a good that's it
yeah does that work yeah it's pretty
good pretty
good not bad yeah so guys get it get on
over in there and dos Suns for anybody
who's uh listening and not seeing it
it's what about people are saying they
don't have Instagram how do how can we
just give them how can we give them away
in a in
a well it's up to you it's your
chocolate yeah I me oh people aren't on
Instagram I don't know what else is easy
though if it was on Instagram they don't
deserve it if they're not on Instagram
yeah if you don't have Instagram you
don't get chocolate easy you want to
stick around for the the eel pit segment
what's that segment we finally doing it
yeah or you want to stick around for the
eel pit segment or what what is P we've
taken enough on and they have a basement
level um and a pool down there full of
eels that's it I'm I'm scared I I don't
I don't think I should hang around for
for the eel pit well then if if that's
the case
uh I I appreciate you being here I I
would like to have you stay with us all
day and night but uh I'm sure you have a
like yeah and we'll we'll when we bring
up the new flavors for the holiday you
guys got to test them that would be
great I'm going to go straight back to
Chef Sandy and I'll say no jelly in
those and then thank you please pass on
and no and you know with peace and love
there's no hate yeah no just yeah we
have to um go meet chef Sandy yeah that
would be fun we'll bring her on here and
we'll do another taste test and you can
tell her straight up what you like and
what you don't like one might say we're
family basically yes son Sun number
three right here we'll be the
par is that it yeah that's it thank you
just walk off that was so fun and so
guys Mark brother number
two all right brother number
two and Sons thank you so
much I don't think I've ever eaten that
much chocolate to to the D holy crap so
much
chocolate what an honor I got I try I
tried to give him an out like an hour
ago
yeah you know he wanted to help broker
the piece between me and dream I
appreciate that he a good man Mark think
he was being Jeff or whatever he had a
good insights on everything frankly
chocolateers are generally pretty smart
I think pretty insightful cuz you've met
so many of them yeah
yeah so uh that was
dream dream
called wild fever dream that was fun I
just insta carted some pepid and my
instacart driver said I hope your tummy
stops hurting little mama oh what the
[__] excuse me yo is he coming on to you
let's invite him no I think he was just
like endearing but how old do how old
was he did you see a picture of 30s can
we get a screenshot a screenshot no he
said it to me in person when I grabbed
the bag oh
oh M sorry wait wait wait wait wait
let's call him back hold on what did you
get pepid you got you insta carded peps
it only that's [__] so he was I think
he made a pretty good observation there
yeah cuz if you're just instarding one
thing and it's pepid you're going
through something yeah well it was pepid
and aqua 4 oh yes that's this is all
medical what did you say doing I just
said thank you he said little mama
that's a throwback I haven't heard
little mama is he Cuban or something I
don't know who like is that is he just a
white guy um no I'm not sure I don't I'm
not sure what his ethnicity not that
Cubans say that but I just I imagine
just very specific I don't know if that
I'm sure some Cubans do say that but I
just I don't know where you got Cuban I
don't know I just for some reason imag
like
Scarface Mama we love the Cubans though
and we kid them it's just he's just
looking out for me we kid them and we
love them I love how you're inching that
closer to you yeah like say what I love
how you're pulling the button closer to
you what what happened we're getting
close to the button oh I'm not pushing
it
no I'm just no there's a cool one piece
sticker here that stole my
oh yeah uh I stuck that on there the
other day that was from a fan I like it
yeah it's cool it's very
cute we have another guest actually this
is just a yeah it's a blockbuster
episode who I think we should make this
one quick I I almost thought about
skipping it but he's been he's emailed
me every like two minutes for the last
half hour oh cuz I told him that we
would have him on soon well he's just
like hey I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
okay ready ready ready so anyways and he
just he just popped
in go ahead I'm so glad we have one of
our yeah and I didn't want to do it with
Mark here so hello Mark not ready for
exactly I and I wouldn't want to subject
him to
that his chocolate would suffer C man
you
here C
man one of the most coveted sought after
guests on the H3 podcast still he can't
hear us yet it is caman who has a giant
[__] apparently although I got to say
didn't we there you go he's connected to
the C man did we talk about this already
I don't know I think we did off air not
with him okay Sean so you said you've
got this huge [__] and that everybody
just worships the ground you walk on
right oh he can't hear me okay I'll wait
run to the bathroom that's a hell of a a
leading though well see man we're you
there's no boundries with us we you
know I'm here I'm here hold on I'm here
hey what's up everybody where the hell
am I sorry
I up Hi C man nice to see you you look
good you look healthy thank you trying
to lose some weight a little bit I've
been you know eating not really the
greatest foods I know that hey what do
you did I ever ask you what's your day
job it hasn't been up in a while I got
new it hasn't been up it hasn't been up
in a while so I haven't really met
anybody worth it do stuff day job day
job well that's not oh wait a minute
wait wait can I hear anything hold
on
wait can you hear Hey C man me can you
hear all right so I was asking I was
asking what is your day
job
there's something wrong with the volume
I
[Laughter]
think see
man what what is your day
job I I do many different things okay
you're you're a jack of all trades
yes I'm driving and doing delivery parts
now here in New York y I deliver auto
parts
M okay I have I got to hit you with
something last time we talked you were
telling these stories about how you go
to these
uh these bath houses and you've got like
a monster [__] that everybody just
follows you around
right hold on I think I got
um wait a minute there's something with
my volume here I got to go ahead and I'm
retelling that accurately right I
believe from the evidence we've seen
yes I heard Zach just go crazy right now
Z can you send me a why is he going
crazy for what
happened we nothing really Zach can you
or not you specifically can someone send
me a picture of because he I mean this
is all public he's a performer just send
it to me on on the
Discord I uh I don't know what happened
to it yeah so can you hear me c man I
deliver auto parts for mechanics I do
auto parts
have you ever uh had an entanglement
with any of the mechanics cuz I feel
like they'd be just your
type I would really really love to be
with a hot mechanic you better believe
it but if I find the one but does it
turn you on their hands are all greasy
and kind of just like cuz you like the
whole car
thing I like anything with a man whether
it's a car a park yeah anything goes so
okay okay I have an important question
for you C man
last we spoke you were telling us a
story about how you went to
a uh a
spa or something where a bunch of gay
men frequent it a bath house and you
said you keep you mentioned that you
have a monster [__]
right yes
well is it TR is it true you have a
monster or
[Laughter]
[Music]
[__]
see man yes so is it yeah so is it true
that you have a monster
[__] yeah at times it's not like that
every minute of the day I mean who the
hell is going to be you know 10:00 in
the morning I'm doing my job my dick is
not going to be sticking out somewhere
no but I mean like so you told us the
story about how you went to a bath house
yes that's common for it's common for
okay no I know no but I'm specifically
talking about like when you you
mentioned that people are just following
you around because you've got this
monster like 9 inch or something right
because I was turned on I have to be
turned on I mean right I'm not really
I'm not really gonna be like that every
minute of the day understand well I
understand how penis measurement works
well look at this my job all day is I
drive I drive in I
deliver yes when it's when it's erected
and ready to go pretty much how is there
okay there's like a 20 second delay that
was crazy right yeah what's this delay
I that was fast that delay is crazy and
the the quality of his feed seems wait
are you are you watching me on stream C
man are you responding to me on stream
oh wait a minute let
me hold on I got a problem with Spectrum
Wi-Fi Spectrum sucks you
there is
no you you're talking to the stream
slightly delay am I where is the stream
I don't know what do you have YouTube
open C
man C I have YouTube open yes okay maybe
close that YouTube and then we'll just
talk through zoom
zoom okay I'll close YouTube Let me
close it let me close
it I got let me get the zoom back I
gotta say dude um am I on Zoom uh maybe
is it clear now is it better now is it
better now can Okay C man put your hand
up if when you hear
me go ahead
speak I can't hear you C man put your
hand up when you hear me say
this I can hear you okay it's a it's a
it's a little it's a little delayed but
we'll we'll work it out so here's what
we'll do c man when you're done saying
something and I'll do it too just give
it a few seconds so the other person
can respond so anyway the Common Thread
through our talks with you is that you
have a monster [__] but I have to say a
video evidence was sent to
us from your subreddit gay foot fetish
work and so this is was publicly posted
and so I'm just so people know I'm not
being like invasive this I know but that
was just here I mean look I mean here
it's I just don't think that this is the
9 incher that's it well it was at the
time I mean it was getting up there but
it was pretty big this wait hold on are
we sure that this is his dick cuz this
is frankly that is my dick I know my
head looks like
Jesus but how do you know what I'm
looking at that's the only one I have on
Reddit oh so you okay so it is you
you're recording right I recorded it yes
dude I got the whole thing was the whole
thing was I was getting erected I didn't
have time for the film I went back 2
minutes later hold on see man this is
not a 9in cop I have to call you out a
little bit thing no it was I it looks
pretty that's what the guy told me I
didn't know the number I I measured I'm
not math was not my strongest point in
college I'm sorry okay okay so so maybe
the [__] size was exaggerated for the
sake well he the guy told me he say like
that's pretty big but you know I'm not
here to discuss about [__] I'm just here
to discuss about
just feet anything you named it okay but
anyway you asked me earlier no see man
well okay this was you know I do auto
part deliveries throughout Queens
Brooklyn and Long Island I do auto pars
to mechanic other jobs as well El watch
this this I got to say this is one of
the weirdest pornos I've ever
seen say yes always be naked in the
office love those feet here I'll maybe
you guys can hear the audio hold
on don't give anybody a free show it's
it's it's no it's on Reddit this is this
is a public post even the audio though I
don't well they're not like in like
crazy quas or anything they kind of just
chilling yeah I don't this every day is
so much fun it's a little office here so
I was mumbling I think I was mumbling I
don't see where the Reddit is let me
find my
Reddit happy happy is a day long is
really good you feel good I was talking
behind the
camera and so and
so how does this just a sample my
professional video is not that I had to
give a sample to get people on the video
so when you buy the video not me him
this is you have to get people on T So
are these two guys you got they're like
paid actors or they just yes they like
this L and their PID of course I pay all
my of course I want you
know over
there I what I was going to do was I was
going to do a um a voice D and do an
interview but the camera ran out so I
had to go
charge so we went to another new scene
anyway that's interesting so if so
people can watch this on your on your
website I guess if they want the whole
show no I have my just for fans page oh
you do so start of charging I I got to
fix my website yeah my website had a lot
of issues and it turned out that it just
cost a lot of money to rebuild another
one so I'm G to try to get another one
rebuilt I'm going to do more videos
again so I just been very busy with some
personal stuff here in New York city so
I just have to really you know um do
things and plus I work all day doing
Auto par deliveries in my car so you
know it's really hard when you're stuck
in traffic you have the time to do
anything make phone calls and try to do
[__] because you know how often can you
make phone calls when you drive I mean I
Bluetooth but still it's see man you
sent us an interesting email a few
months ago it was it wrote only this it
said only
this uh wait what was the email exactly
uh Dan do you remember about that the Fe
Andrew Tate's feet you said oh yes I
wanted I was curious about
andw email you sent us an email that
only said this I want to see Andrew
Tate's
feet Yes because I was really horny one
down I was watching the UFC or something
and all these guys had H feet and they
kept just everybody's kept talking about
Andrew Andrew I watched the
British show and I'm like and I did see
his feet but I was like kind of a glance
and then I looked at another wrestler
and I'm like that was pretty hot I still
want to Sean Mendes but I mean so do you
think we have access to his feet
pictures or what was your expectation
that we could help you I saw it on one
of the YouTube channels but I mean I'm
sure they are pretty hot I mean he's
he's a he's a sports person so that's
pretty cool well let's take a look
here's wik
feet we'll take a look here I I'm I'm
gonna answer your uh your Jesus
man do you know about Wiki you know
about this website right yeah I don't
like it sucks oh you don't like it I
agree I mean here what do you I mean
this is you get a pretty good shot of
him what do you think about that that's
pretty hot yeah pretty good oh by the
way that dream
guy watching that dream guy is pretty
cute by the way that dream guy they
showed me the thing picture oh you know
who dream is no I just heard it like
five minutes
ago I got on okay but he didn't show
himself
I heard a part that he was sliding his
house and he fell down before gu you
know that's the part I I I heard here's
dreams feed I don't know if you have any
comments here's it's not a lot to go up
but that's
dreams that's kind of blurry yeah oh
it's dreams feed that's pretty can't see
blurry anyway let's go over these I'm
curious so here your just give me your
thoughts as I go through
them that's pretty hot Souls look nice
nice Souls
mhm you
know got beautiful feet what about this
one this like I said a lot of like I
said a lot of guys have nice feet they
just don't realize they're
self-conscious
right what the [__] is this what are
these
crazy uh here we go okay so this what do
you think about this with the who is
this guy first who is this guy Andrew
Tate Andrew Tate it's the guy you
literally about okay that's that's right
because I I remember
the I did remember see the face one so
he's got pretty feet yeah I watched a
few YouTube so I watch a lot of many
videos on so what do you think about
this one this one is almost feet
forward yeah it's pretty nice you like
that one yeah I mean it's just a
original laying in your bed I mean it's
different if it's in different areas or
different scenes it could be pretty what
what would you do to his feet if you
were in the room with
them well I don't want to discuss that
your so but you could pretty much figure
out what yeah I'll we can use our
imaginations
yes but anyway so how you thought that
dream was Mark dream was Mark oh the oh
maybe you're right maybe that is what's
happening oh here's an interesting one
his F do you like the curved kind of
thing happening
here wait one second
yeah what curv his foot is curved it's
like
arched oh yeah that's kind of
you know not bading the muscles yeah
pretty
good and then just based on this photo
if you could pick one person's feet to
worship who would you choose out of
these five
gentlemen hold on I'm trying to get that
little box is not working for me there
something with the Audio I got to get
back on on the video itself see if I see
myself I'm sorry go
ahead can you see the picture I'm trying
to show you
I I I I lost I'm just I'm on your
YouTube live I'm just trying to get on
it if that works again I
hate these commercials try to find the
zoom you can hear me turning on YouTube
right I'm turning on YouTube yeah but
okay there now I can YouTube You're he's
you're watching the stream
now I'm watching The Stream should I not
watch is that what well it definitely
add to the delay it would be really slow
yeah it's way behind it's way behind
where we are actually talking oh it is
yeah 20 20 30 seconds or something so
you don't know that you can't tell the
difference in time 30 seconds and right
now all right well I guess I can get off
that yeah I see it was pretty nice so of
these Five
Guys whose feet would you choose to
worship if you had to pick
one I can I can zoom in too yeah hold on
let me oh [__] let me see one hold on
pretty much any of them they're all
pretty hot I mean I'm sure any gay guy
that just go nuts of all these guys
pretty so you could you couldn't
pick I mean probably do all my not you
have to pick there there's a gun to your
head they say Andrew Tate okay Andrew
Tate we like Andrew he's got nice Fe I
know I actually heard him speak on on an
interview he's pretty pretty good pretty
interesting know yeah what was he
talking about I remember just some
sports events about you know some of the
people and how you know some people were
not getting along with other people and
certain things it was a while back a
long time
yeah um have you heard of a website
there's something I also want to ask you
about uh feat finder have you been oh
yeah I've seen that but there's a lot of
fakes with that I found oh it's actually
a lot of fake people and it's actually
like robots people don't people don't I
heard it's a lot of scammers like that's
why I'm not there asking for
I won't give money and that's the
problem so would you the issue I find
out so you've never used that
website no I I went on it once but it
turned out to be I think it's just all
robots and fake people and just scamming
people surpris I went in there yeah I
went in there and someone asked you for
money right away and I'm like I'm not
giving you money it's [__] you know
if you really like this [__] these
people are fake hold on but that so I
guess but it's for like buying feed pics
so I guess it makes I know but the thing
is but like I said to you earlier a lot
of people that AR the feed are trying to
sell [__] and don't know what anybody
wants half the [__] they're in there
just push the nobody wants I don't know
what they're selling because I ask
somebody a question he's like I'm just
he just takes a shoe off and wants to
sell a video I mean you didn't even put
any effort into they posers know I mean
it's just it's ridiculous if you're
gonna put quality in something that's
what I'm saying I make good quality
videos because I love this and I'm proud
of this people who know this and love
this are in this industry can make
something good quality you know you just
sit in the throat [__] out there expect
people to buy stuff is ridiculous right
you know like I said is I you know I'm
not saying that people want to try but
the thing is you know obviously you
don't like this [__] because you're not
put on effort see man how is um how's
the website performing I know you have
your own business and producing uh adult
entertainment right yeah I'm doing it on
my just for fans page because I found it
and how was business are you doing well
there I got about 10 15 guys in but the
problem is is it's just really hard now
the adult industry with a with with with
just making videos because a lot of
people are competing and not only that
is a lot of people want stuff for free
what I'm hearing and I've been really
going back and forth a lot of people
like well I just want to jerk off and
they loved my short one minute video but
I'm not giving somebody a 15minute video
to jerk off no way that's bull money I
mean I mean I work my ass off every
every day driving delivering Auto Parts
to mechanics other places but not only
that is I make six 700 a week and I'm
busting my ass to put all my money into
my business and then I'm trying to get
another job until I find you know till I
get the business really started
somewhere you
know try to get Space to rent an office
stuff but I'm not giving for free and
people just don't they want everything
for free and it's pissing me off so
you're trying to help your own Community
doing good videos that people want this
it just seems like this just seems like
even many adult sites are are failing
that they're all going to just for fans
because they figured I can get that
quick but even so so much competition so
C man you say you've got about 15
followers 15 guys who bought my my just
F hopefully there'll be more it's only
is that a monthly um payment you get or
is that a monthly paid that's good nice
plus I was also trying to re-evaluate
what I want to do I might decide to also
get into full-blown porn with the feet
because I figured you know I I do want
to do the feed stuff but I also want to
do a side thing where it's full-blown
porn with the feet obviously
everything's going to have feet included
because that's what that's what I was
always kind of advocating for because
you seem comfortable being in you know
entertainment and you know this just the
feed is so Niche I feel like you you
might do really well if you participate
in some kind of more mainstream
stuff well like I said I I got so sick
of it because it's too
much that and that's what I'm saying is
even though it's only about a handful of
foot s sites and people are doing a
great job and I commend our brothers out
there doing a lot of foot stuff so
that's why but my thing is that I
figured well um you know basically if I
could at least try to get something you
know on a full foot stuff because like I
said there's not much of the full foot
because people tell me I do like other
things besides feet but it's good to see
feet but my dilemma I have is in a lot
of porn and you know I even Hur in
straight porn where they you know no
one's really doing a lot of other things
in the body and the thing is um you know
when you're turned on by someone you do
want to explore sexually with a person I
know porn in general is has included
many fetishes in the past and then it
stopped at about eight nine years where
everything was just straight you know
the [__] and people got tired of it I
spoke a lot of people years ago about
this and they're like we want to bring
the other things back to make the porn
scenes more exciting so a lot of
directors are including the feet you
know armpits whatever other fetishes
they have and
are Fe can I draw your attention to this
clip
here Christ that is hold on I'm a t i
got a big dick he wants he's a he's
Itali how big are we talking C
man I don't I don't that's something I
really can't discuss you just said you
you got a big one well it's more than
nine and less than 12 so you fig dude
see man that wasn't true was
it what that you said you said between 9
and 12
inches um well that's what the guy told
like I said me measured it like I said I
didn't think it'd be 11 12 I always knew
I was always eight and a half n most of
my life because when I push it really
hard because I get really super turned
on like I said there's moments when I'm
really turned on with
some C man I don't want to be rude like
and I hate to call you out but you I'm
just you don't have C man I'm just
saying because the point is all you
don't need to steal the big dick Valor
because listen as a lot of us guys we we
we wish we were bigger but like you know
it's just
not I'm just saying is I am big but it's
not like I'm big every minute of the day
I mean no one's going to be like that
you know about you know shopping in
[__] store eating something you're
not going to be hard I won't argue I
can't show the photo obviously so we're
not getting
anywhere but you've seen you all seen it
right yeah this was my first time what
did you think is that a and again just
to
just I
mean well you just hold on hold on on
would you describe it as big penis no no
well I would say I like I said I was
told that I never me mentioned it okay I
mean but maybe maybe he's a grower and
not a shower I mean we to me well the
whole thing is there are times when I am
really big but the thing is I don't have
tell me hold on you're telling me one
day you're at the bath house and
suddenly yes a place you're going to be
big it's common sense I believe him so
hold on one day cuz seen it in the in
the porno I would say that's like
probably an average maybe five
in no offense I'm just telling you like
I see because I was I know but I said I
was getting up there I wasn't ful no
that looked Tor I know but it was not
fully erect I still had more time
because when I didn't do the other shoot
when I was an hour later I was
completely big and the GU guy came over
goes why didn't you shoot this I said I
didn't think about it I was just trying
to do a t video so you're telling me
hold on see man you're telling me you go
into a bath house and you go magically
from 5 in to 12 I mean how does that
work it's like more than double the size
because when you it's common sense with
dudes we have penises we know we're
getting turned on little by little you
get you don't just go zeros you have to
build your heart on pretty much that's
pretty much how that works I mean you
know I've had a dick my whole life duh
so the thing is you know you're G to get
you're G to go from up to up to up and
eventually get to the highest point to
listen Hey listen when I when I cook my
spaghetti it gets a little bigger but
it's you know what I mean it's not it's
not it doesn't keep
growing well I'm just saying is because
I'm just a horny person I can't help it
I mean there's you know I like that's
nothing wrong with sex I like being
dirty and horny I mean it's just nature
all right very good you know so I'm just
saying that that video I took on Reddit
I mean like I said a guy told me I was
11 I didn't believe it I said to him I
was just took the picture I was getting
turned on because that was the very
beginning of the 15minute video near the
end I was I was getting harder and
harder but when you start the video you
start getting turned on like any adult
video you make the
person so when he told you nine is it
possible he was talking in centimeters
and like
metric cuz nine centimeters would be
closer to what I saw no offense of
course I don't know but look look but
it's five or seven I was getting up
there I mean I was getting but now
you're okay but hold on cuz you're
saying if it's five or seven before and
once again just go back to exhibit
a okay we go back to like I said first
of all that video was the beginning of
me getting turned on okay I mean you
know when you're acting in video you
have to get turned on you know I mean I
I was doing it and I said well let me
take a picture now and then I had done
the whole video and I figured well I
put the clips of that one in because I
wasn't going to go spend all this time
to put the other one on Reddit I wanted
you know reddits appoint the teachers to
get some of to buy my stuff let me hold
on hold on hold on let me direct your
attention to exhibit a hold on all right
I feel like just said you you got a big
one well it's more than nine and less
than 12 so you fig oh my goodness more
than nine and less than 12 grocery store
because at that because there
are that's what I'm saying it's not
like I'm like that every day there are
moments that I'm like there moments I'm
like that I can get that high but it's
not like a permanent thing my thing is
I've been that but not like I don't
think many guys can ever be that that
much every day that's you know that's
difficult unsustainable it's not be
dangerous I think our understanding of
penises are different like I understand
that based on how turned on it can
affect how torqued you get right but
like yes of course but like but
generally let's I'll just speak for
myself and apologies for the crassness
to the people listening um if I'm hard
as you
say there's certainly a variance but
maybe by like an inch at
most I'm not seeing six inch swings in
my size
ever I have I mean I'm just different
I'm just really pent up sexual stuff I
can't help it you know hold on I
actually have okay so here this is a
comment you left on the thread you said
yes I was ereck but getting there I was
hard but not super boned yet yes I wrote
that and I was trying to get fully erect
I came the scene before but it was hard
to get hard again so fast after coming I
I should have waited a bit that's true
that's common sense look I'm in my 40s
dude I'm not 19 I can come 18 times a
day let me finish hold on and then
you'll have your chance to respond s in
context this backs up what he was saying
I should have waited a bit I I have
waited I should have waited for a few
more scenes once I blew a load it's hard
to get it's it need to get hard again
the main point of the video was feet and
foot fetish not really [__] he B that's
true but I did I added it because one
guy said maybe it's good to do the [__]
to get people know because some guys
want to see the [__] as well in the feet
and I said we're not full-blown porn I
didn't really want to bring a lot of
[__] stuff in different scenes because
that's not the business model now but I
put it out as a teaser and then he I
said if we start going this way you know
I wasn't doing a lot of [__] stuff so
like I said I blew load earlier before
the shoot because we were just we were
fing around a lot of us were and I was
turned on so when you blow a load it's
not easy to get a heart again any guy
knows that I mean
really I'm young but I'm not 20 where I
can blow understand that I look I'm s
I'm having problems with this I am why
because he's first you're making the
claim that you're between 9 and 12 this
is this is Sten Val I'm not every day I
was 9 and 12 at certain periods I can
get that high you hold on see man hold
on you said here you're erect you said
you're not fully erect but you are I'm
erect yeah there's a
difference I know know but he's saying
he was trying to get there hold on I was
trying to get there because
I see man
listen you were showing about a four or
five inches in my opinion I get again
hold on C man and you said here it was
erect not fully erect now if I'm erect
and not
because when you're not erect you're one
inch when you're walking around every
damn day everyone's tiny when they're
not erect that's common sense I of
course but you said you're a wreck so if
I'm looking at like four or five inches
how much bigger when you get fully
torqued you're not going to be adding on
seven eight well I have pushed myself
sometime like I told you and I was in
pain one day and I really hurt myself to
push myself because I really want to get
what does that mean how do you push
yourself I really because I was so
turned on and I was just really just
seeing you know pushing my body inside
me and I got really one day so turned on
that I pushed myself really hard and it
hurt it hurts to push yourself really
hard I have goals for myself because a
lot of times when I was younger I was
not I guess 100% confident with my dick
size so I would push harder harder
harder and then when I got bigger it
started causing me pain so I said I got
to stop this because that was I was my
so are you doing some kind of training
that makes it larger some kind of
extension no I just get so turned on and
I just wait to come and I just tease
myself instead of coming right away I'll
take myself maybe 20 or 30 minutes wait
myself to come and I hurt myself and I
actually one day thought I had to go to
the doctor because I really had so much
pain TR to get big because I wanted to
be big you know I was in my late 30s at
that time people with penises here with
this I don't understand the explanation
it's not like a kneading dough I mean
you know it doesn't keep getting bigger
and bigger and bigger want that
confident person I never had I never had
hookups but sounds like you've never
pushed I don't know what pushing means
okay pushing myself to the Limit I mean
pushing myself to the Limit okay because
my thing is because my thing is look if
you're turned on like said there's
levels of being turned on right you turn
at the moment and then you go I want to
go deeper deeper instead of before you
climax you wait the
climax he's edging if I he's
and wait until finally I can either hurt
myself if it just explodes inside my
body until I get out and explod it
because the point is I shouldn't do that
because you know I mean I guess I guess
while I was getting older I guess I
still want to be young and so being
young means you can be big and do what
you want so that's why I'm trying p hold
on you're saying that as you as you edge
yeah you get yes your your your member
gets bigger and bigger and bigger does
it ever stop getting bigger
no it gets big to a certain level but I
keep trying to push myself bigger and I
keep my mind you make it sound like your
dick is like going super saing I just
not sure that that's how it works it's
powering up it it would make it would
make your uh ejaculate more rather than
your uh the the size it makes sense to
me that's what I do but as it builds up
makes sense yeah every guy yeah I I
stand I I stand over my wife and I go
like that oh you will it y hold on baby
I'm hold on baby I'm only at 5 in give
me give me 20 minutes it's like a water
balloon I just like a water balloon I
mean Secrets I'd love to hear him but I
just sounds like he do no but the thing
was what got me I guess one of my
friends is why don't you get one of
these rubber extension things to make it
bigger cuz I okay now we're talking so
what is that but that hurt when I did
that and I seen all those old 60 and 70y
old creepy men doing I said I'm not 70
I'm I should have a
natur that's what I said so I figured
let me do it natural by pushing it
myself having pains on my freaking chest
and I feel like I'm having a heart
attack so do you yeah that doesn't sound
good so are do I know it doesn't sound
good but you know when I that was when I
was my late 30s I knew I was getting
older now that I'm 4ing I don't care
because I'm still young and I look good
even though I'm older I'm 20 where I can
go for 17 hours you know you know so
hold on C man do you take supplements or
drugs or anything to help no I don't do
drugs I do vitamins I'm a Heth I do
vitamin I don't do V
isic that
magnesium calcium magnesium no I just
take vitamins just just magnesium
vitamin I'm just saying look I'm just
saying is I but me I'm the kind of
person I have levels when you know how
we can SLE this here's how we settle
this and I I wouldn't ask I I'm going to
come there I'm going to go
there in your studio I'm going to jerk
off and I'm going to show you not what
I'm asking for I not asking for that but
what I am suggesting if you're
comfortable let's see a photo of the 9
to 12 inches as you as you purport send
it when I find a hot guy to do it with
I'm supposed to you don't have it but
you're a performer surely there's a
photo on hand there's got to be aot on
because a lot of the photos I don't take
my dick out I just do the foot worship
and lick feed tuck toes you don't have a
picture of your [__] I don't normally
take it out I did that one time as a
teaser or like I said not doing
full-blown porn as I'm going to do it
down the road I actually will do more
you don't jerk off though like you don't
chub up or anything I do jerk off but I
did it behind camera before we started
rolling because I was turned on and I
jerked off we all jerked off wait did
you jerk off the
dream no I said to I
said not the video sh that day when I
shot that video I jerked off I was so
turned on and I think if I didn't jerk
off I probably would have been bigger
because I was waiting but I was that's
probably what happened sense so no ELA
it it doesn't make sense you don't know
what you're talking about I think I know
what a penis is I've had one my whole
life so yeah he's okay hold on hold on
hold on you're okay so humbly request
next time you're between 9 and
12 send us a photo because I I'm not
trying to see I'm not trying to be a but
what I
saw it wasn't it wasn't even close man I
I know but I was telling people that I
was getting up the next time when I'm
totally erect I will send it and believe
me I'll send it I'm not I'm not shame
when you were when you were on that
shoot do you do you just finish by
yourself before you shoot just to kind
of get it out of your system or did you
do it in collaboration with the other
actors well I just like a total guy who
just blow load n tip just that's it get
on with it
and did you and did you blow the load on
the carpet or the floor or was it done
in some kind it was in my pants was
pants right so my pants were were dry
coming right at least it's it's
contained it's contained now is that why
you took off your pants for this but at
least but at least there wasn't a damn
plastic bag like that guy in a bat house
which was wild that was a crazy story a
plastic
bag I don't think you know about the
plastic bag we did you someone asked you
you were in the bathro house and people
were worshiping your [__] so much this
guy came to you with a plastic band and
said can you please come in this bag for
me to take home right yeah he was so
strange that dude because he's to keep
my [__] keep my my [__] and as a
remembrance and play with my really
weird
[Music]
yeah
we're not showing it we're not showing
it all right please don't show your
crotch
anymore my pants are on I know I know I
know YouTube they get a little touchy
about stuff it's fine yeah I know so
you're
so you are saying that you are currently
wearing pants with dried seen no not
these ones no I wash my I wash my pants
I don't yeah he's good he's clean and so
when and so when you came in your pants
during the shoot was it um was it a why
you asking all these crazy
questions you know everything I me I I
don't sit there and look at my come
that's so stupid you go hold on hold on
hold on you say you come in your pants
were you was this a
handsfree orgasm or like how do you do
that well it was a handsfree I had to
touch it to get so it doesn't drip
everywhere so you know because it could
start dripping everywhere it's not good
so but I do handsfree normal yeah I W so
you you do hand impressive because
because I'm so turned on that I'm just
at the start dripp see you have some
special power 4S I started
dripping
like a you're like a monk that pushes
himself to the outer limits of what the
body's e ja is impossible dude you guys
don't remember his paper towel aisle
story he
came remember whole thing yeah it's like
a fire hose he just aims it once it's so
because like I don't know if you've
heard about like there's there's monks
like in Tibet that have pushed their
body to the Limit that they can do what
most people would think was a
supernatural for example they'll go out
into a blizzard and through the power of
their mind raise their body temperature
so that they can survive through the
blizzard and I believe that you are
doing some kind of similar Mystic some
kind of chi related just Body Mind
Spirit uh you have some kind of
technique here don't know because you're
breaking the human ever since my 20s
when I get very sexual my body was
always you know I was always free with
my body but you know as I got older I
just was like you know I I guess I
wanted to do more and I just started
pushing myself to limits because I'm
like well let me because I always hear
people say well do this do this do this
it's like and I got have friends like I
said that want to do the [__] extensions
with the rubber and that's horrible I
mean it hurts I tried it and they buy
them in these stores and it hurts your
body it's mut mutilated yeah and I don't
I don't know if you know this but like
talking about going up to your limit is
interesting like one in one punch man
that's how Sait well I
mean got so powerful is that
Lim I guess my reason my limit I guess
when I was younger like I said I'm the
most confident person but you know
everyone has a little bit of hookups and
I was a little bit self-conscious a
little bit not a lot and I guess when I
went out to parties in New York City you
know you meet all these guys and it's
like you know I never had muscles I
looked good I had a nice body but you
know meet these guys and they're like so
this this and this and come to find out
they were on steroids and I never did
drugs in my life and I'm happy about
that I'm proud of that and I always felt
why can't I have a big you know I'm
Italian I'm goodlooking what the hell's
wrong with me you know I mean and I
always had that I mean a lot of guys I
just I didn't know having a big dick was
a
choice well it's it's kind of not it
kind of is but it depends how you're
born with your genus you know what I
mean and my thing is I just I mean some
people born with big ones some aren't
it's just human nature I guess but I
guess I felt that I wanted one of those
I guess you know people want you know
big old homes and fancy cars I want a
nice
big there's just the logic is not making
sense am I losing my mind
got a super power you said you used to
have a small dick I'm not saying small I
would say average when I was in my 20s
and it got you know whatever big and I
used to do find ways to make myself
bigger because that's one thing I wanted
in your 20s you had a average size
that's average size no one complained
I've had a lot of dat but now you've
decided and willed into existence a 9 to
12 incher doubling the size let's go
dude at moments that's at at Great
Moments of of of human limit power
manifestation well I mean I was taking
like herbal vitamins and doing a lot of
stuff and I was doing a lot of you know
drinking all these you know you know
there those pwds people drink and did
all the different things so maybe so was
drug assisted in some way well it's it's
vitamins I guess if you want to call
Vitamin A drug I've always don't like
vitamin it's not a no vitamin is not a
drug but I mean and I know I'm a healthy
person but I guess those my my hookups
and I shouldn't be self-conscious
because you growing up in New York is
not easy anyway you know what I mean you
always had these people had these
hookups and I I never had a problem
people always tell me why do you care
you're beautiful person I like you the
way you are and I just I guess when
you're in your 30s you feel like these
people you know it's something you go to
a sex party you feel like okay I'm I'm
hot why can't I be like that I it's
human nature you know what I mean and I
guess I've always tried myself I've
always pushed myself to the limits and I
used to hurt myself like I me one time I
was really painful when I came out of a
party I'm like I just got sit down I had
to drink water because I was really
pushing myself and I was trying to come
and I didn't force myself to come until
finally I said I have to hurt myself if
I don't let it out and I let it out and
it felt better but now as you get older
when you ejaculate it's going to take
time to get turned on again I it needs
recharge you're young you can keep doing
it 25 times in a day and get done with
okay you know I miss those 20s you know
when that day but now you're people
saying why can't you comprehend this
Ethan what am I crazy all right I'm not
a little what he's explained it very
clearly I get what you're saying C man
you're like a X-Man except your dick
grows bigger I mean if it's a mutant
power I understand I'm not saying grows
bigger I'm just saying is maybe I'm just
not pushing my heart on as big enough
that's the problem I'm I'm getting hard
limit I'm not I'm I'm not I'm not
pushing my heart onto the full limit get
it that's the point is p heart what you
um no I believe in you yeah that's true
push hard CU some people tell me I'm
hard a little bit or I'm not fully hard
I'm like what am I ugly not you should
be fully turned on by me but they're
like this people may have health
problems I don't know I mean people tell
me that I'm only wrecked a certain point
but how's your how's your blood pressure
do you have good blood pressure very
good good I'm very
healthy cuz that I drink a lot of coffee
though that's the only thing is a lot of
C I don't think there's a problem with
coffee you're stuck in New York traffic
on the Bell Parkway and then you get on
the the Van Wick never moves and the
damn southern state which so windy that
kind of turns me on so windy sometimes
too wait why oh the road the road I
don't know something about the southern
state park but I have weird stories
about I can tell you that story and so
hold on and so when you're driving the
road do you do a a hand no hands uh
while you drive no one time I I'll tell
you one one time I got turned on in
Southern State Park where I was coming
from Long Island from Club way out going
towards the the the ferry going out to
um I I think Fire Island and I was
getting out Bayshore and I was getting
hexa State Park and I get on the
southern state and it's very windy it's
a very windy road in Long
Island York it's not in New York City
and I was just for some reason that day
just the winding just kind of got me a
little bit and I was trying to play with
myself as I was driving it I never
really play with myself when I drive
because we want to hold the wheel and
that was when I had a I had my friend's
bigger car that was back in like the
late 90s I remember that story I was
young too and I was like what the hell
let me just play with us night time and
it was hard cuz you lose you know you
want to hold the wheel it's so windy
that one little thing you could lose
control and that's scary especially when
it gets towards NASA Farmingdale and
then so it's Amityville Rockville Center
to Queen Park so did anything happen or
it was just that was just an an
anecdote it was an antidote I guess
basically because you know I guess just
you know that day I didn't hook up I
really liked someone and I wanted to
hook up and I was turned on and it was
just like oh I'll see you again I'm like
well you can give me what I want so well
C man listen I'm I believe we've heard
it
all well the thing is I I mean I like I
said I'm the most honest person but like
I was trying to explain like I said that
in that email and that that thing I
wrote on my um Reddit was the truth like
I had to wait to get turned on again
because you know it's not easy at your
age do this Con I'm gonna have to do
yeah I I I'm that makes sense I'm gonna
have to do some more oh you know what I
wanted to watch this with you Fe oh
maybe I shouldn't yeah it's probably
bad I looked at it there's but I think
the website it's probably not a good
well C man it's been great to hear from
you yeah yeah yeah well I want to tell
everybody that I have more shoots coming
up in Miami Florida in January I have an
office scene which is really good and
I'm going to do more wrestling scenes
the office scene will be really hot when
get some more um guys there and I'm
going to do some more driving videos as
well I'm going to do a really good box
truck video driving around New York City
in a box truck and what's a
Bo box truck 16 foot box truck cuz I
used to drive a box truck sometime and I
used to have fun it's a Sentimental
project yeah have you ever well it's
kind be nice
truck have you ever come on a gas
pedal well no it's hard to get it's
really hard that's very low down there
it's very hard to get down there but I
guess if I had my body laying on the in
the box truck you can lay flat and you
can like worship a person's football
he's driving which is pretty hot
I you know I was just curious cuz like
you said it difficult I mean if I'm
aiming on the ground I probably could
but yeah yeah okay a box truck is small
we're going to do a lot of hot erotic
videos on box CHS fans maybe a big
Escalade knows something good and do a
nice video around New York City you know
Queens Brooklyn Bruns get C man uh
listen it's always a pleasure we love to
hear from we love you we love to hear
from you I'm sorry about the audio what
happened with the audio in the beginning
because apparently apparently I missed
the beginning part because it was like a
double speaking like I don't know what
happened was it because I went on the
YouTube or something yeah it's the
YouTube probably but it wasn't too bad
no everything's fine I went on YouTube
last time and I have a problem I don't
know because it was like really loud so
I couldn't hear myself but but yeah so I
like I said I I oh I was going to tell
you a really weird story today I was
sitting parked because you know you
can't talk with a cell phone and even
have Bluetooth and I'm sitting parked
looking at my app for my next delivery
because again I deliver order parts
throughout queens and
um places and apparently this car edged
me like almost had an access sideswiped
me I'm like what the [__] because he's
two old people and I'm like what the
hell I mean like it must been eight8
years old didn't see my car and I guess
she was going in her house or going
because I was parked in front of
someone's house
on9th Avenue and um in in Richmond Hill
Ozone Park Queens it's really crazy over
there and I got so mad I'm like I got
out and I black smudge on on the edge of
my of my tire I'm like I have a white m
though you know and that car I try to
keep nice and you know what the hell
it's like I so get out and scream at I
go up to the car and it's an old lady
I'm like oh my God I'm so know people
are driving something years old you you
realized that it was a old couple and
then your the anger left your body want
claim it to the insurance I didn't want
to make an action I just was a little
bit of a scrape but I don't like that I
mean that just pisses me off it's like
but people in New York just don't give a
[__] this is what pisses me off you know
you work your ass off and then you know
they're running red light Brooklyn's to
work I mean they're driving on sidewalk
well C man it's been a joy I hope you
have a fantastic weekend please reach
out again we'd love to hear from you
yeah yeah definitely and like I said I'm
G to get to La one day I'll definitely
come in the studio
show you can show uh who wants to verify
besides uh no I don't think I'm GNA do
there I mean z is that that said
something Zach thing he's got it you
know take me to a hotel I'm not
volunteering anybody take to hotel and
have fun I'm kidding I I don't care I
like to be dirty and while tie my ass up
I tie my ass up and rip my name science
all right science experiment the thing
is you can you can easily do that
yourself the measuring I I so do that
next time okay and send us some
confirmation because I'm just not buying
it well I mean I wish it was have to be
there I guess all right you have to be
there right you have just send me just
send me next to a a ruler man it's not
you know what I mean who who the hell
has a rule when you're doing
your
I tell the people should we stop the
shoot so I can go to Staples and buy a
ruler I mean IM walk Staples jeez I have
to measure my penis the one that meas a
penis really I mean that would be silly
I'm G to ask you a question now you
asked me barding question do you ever
measure yourself or I mean I I don't now
but I have I mean I know how big it
is like plus or minus not 6 in plus or
minus mind
you but please just bring a ruler with
you next time so we can confirm it
independent
confirmation all right that's C man
everybody wow all right see man thank
you so much buddy amazing [__]
amazing always a pleasure really truly a
treat I didn't mean for it to become
this confrontational thing but like I
felt after all the things we've talked
about with him he had really built up
the mythology of this monster mhm [__]
yeah it changes what you're imagining in
your head when he's telling these
stories it does I think it's it's
important information to share like
let's not jump to conclusions yet you
laid down the gauntlet you told him
exactly how he could verify it and let's
see if he comes through mhm and listen
earned that listen I'm not calling him a
liar but what I saw there's no way that
that dick gets bigger in my opinion than
6 in no way and that's and that's being
generous we were seeing round two like
you said that was round two the man also
consistently proves himself as an
anomaly like there's no if anybody is
extra special in this it's definitely
that that's kind of true that's a fair
point right he could figure it
out okay well we're waiting see man we
appreciate it what an episode I mean wow
we've been all over the place huh yeah
we're going on 4 hours so unfortunately
I don't think we'll have time to get to
the eel pit today no that's okay we can
do it next week I know we've been saying
we'll do it but what we'll do it on
Monday
wow wow wow wow wow wow what a journey
learned a
lot you can grow your cck 6 in through
the power of the mind it's common sense
it's like it's like uh you just got to
believe in yourself it's sort of like
Peter Pan you just believe in yourself
and you can fly baby yeah maybe try just
look in the mirror this weekend and what
what what brings uh Tinker Bell back to
life is it clapping applause applause
applause so maybe with enough people
just giving you a round of applause
applause to
live all right listen everybody thank
you for being here a beautiful marvelous
week of shows have we not had tremendous
tremendous tremendous and uh we'll be
back next week for another week of
fantastic marvelous entertainment for
you my beautiful audience and thank you
to the members who make it all
possible although now that I'm getting
that dream money who knows right I
there's no way I take him up on that
right why definitely take why would I
take his money it's so fun he's right
that is a really funny idea to just like
have another YouTuber but like him pay
me like a beautiful like brother like
that'd be so funny he he he's one of the
biggest YouTubers Mr Beast we start with
him and then we go around we ask
different YouTubers hey you know dream
ad with us do you want to advertise with
us yeah one very we make our way up to
Mr Beast forget about it listen we need
all the sponsors we can get here at the
streamy backdrop we could it could say
dream on it you know you can sponsor it
yes yeah on the steping repeat yeah all
right it's so late we love you all so
much we'll see you next week have a
great weekend everybody with peace and
love have a great weekend love y all
next time see you next
time
[Music]
for